and may i first remind
you of some domestic arrangements
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite the stairs
cold water is available in the breakout
area outside the meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound
please leave the meeting room by
following the fire exit signs and meet
on the ipswich town football club
training pitch
do not re-enter the building until you
are told in it is safe to do so
also
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silent
thank you
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting
and all training purposes
council members of the of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
we have a very full agenda of business
to consider this evening and we must
leave the premises before 10 pm
therefore
i ask all councillors to ensure that
their questions and debate
are brief and to the point
and not repeat of others questions or
comments
ensure that we get through all the items
on the agenda i will allow a maximum 45
minutes for questions and debate on each
substantive motion
item whilst
at the same time ensuring that debate is
fair and not curtailed it is my
intention to take a 10-minute break at
an appropriate point
near to half past seven
can i ask councillors to ensure that
they all return to the chamber properly
thereafter
can i also remind all councillors to
speak directly into their microphones
and avoiding putting any papers in front
of them
and i also
for this meeting
we'll
ask members that they may sit when
addressing the chair
okay thank you
chairman to say
can i move to the agenda please
item one apologies for absence
thank you chair i have received
apologies from councillor dawson
councillor gould councillor grandin
councillor holt councillor newman and
councillor mclaren thank you
item two declarations of interest by
councillors
are there any declarations of interest
you know
okay
i shall now go to
item 3 bc 21 stroke 11
to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on 29th of july 2021
for accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
did i then have a proposal please
thank you matt margaret mayberry
councilman
and could i have a second please
thank you mick fraser councillor mick
fraser
thank you i will now ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office to
conduct the vote
thank you chair um councillors i intend
to take this by consensus vote so please
can you raise your hands if you agree to
the minutes thank you
thank you chair that is carried
thank you
bc 2112 announcements from the chairman
and leader
i refer to paper bc
2112 for noting thank you
i have already uh put my the
my
civic duties there
councilwood do you have anything to
report
yeah thank you chair yes just just a few
items
well everyone we are finally back home
at last for tonight's meeting we do
still have some guidelines in place so
that everyone can feel safe but it does
mark another point on a steady return to
normal covert infection rates locally
and nationally remain stubbornly at a
moderate level
which i suppose is to be expected as
people mix a lot more but
hospitalizations and deaths also stable
are reasonably low
it does mean that the message of caution
and sensible use of masks and sanitizers
remains
i do want to take this opportunity to
mention the two award ceremonies at
which baba and midsuffer were successful
recently
two weeks ago i was able to attend the
iez conference and awards ceremony at
church house in london
you'll know by now that we won three
awards a gold silver and bronze
this really is an excellent achievement
and we should all be proud that our
officers are delivering to a high
standard that what we are doing for our
residents is being recognised nationally
obviously winning a bronze in the
council of the year category is very
good but we shouldn't rest on our
laurels and must strive for the gold
award
last week the housing solutions team was
highly commended in the community heroes
of the year category at the municipal
journals achievement awards for their
efforts in keeping vulnerable residents
off the streets during the code 19
pandemic
yesterday i was pleased to accompany
council of fleming of mid-suffolk to the
stone market depot to talk to radio
suffolk about the switch of our vehicle
fleet to run on hvo
and this took place at the weekend
we are the first rural districts to do
this and shows that we are delivering
real benefits for our residents and
their environment as part of our efforts
to reach net zero by 2030
i'm pleased to announce that our 180
thousand pound investment in cctv and
hadley in sudbury is almost fully
operational
we have 21 cameras in sudbury and eight
in hadley four are still to go live
bellevue park and cavernous road in
sudbury and the cricket ground in
pakenham way in hadley
there is also one mobile camera and we
will monitor its use to determine if
more are going to be needed
and finally a last reminder that the
final stage of the women's tour will be
passing through baber on 9th of october
the route takes it through several of
our communities and will enable many of
our residents to watch it should be a
great spectacle
thank you
chair okay clarification please
okay
thank you unreceived
um
item five to receive notifications for
petitions in accordance with the council
procedure rules
non-received chair
thank you
item six questions by the public in
accordance with council procedure rules
chairman to say
i'll refer you to the questions in the
table papers
as laura knight is unable to to be here
this evening i'll read out her question
and the question one laura knight to
councillor hulk who unfortunately is a
member for the economic growth who is
also absent and apologies tonight
the council reports that they have
been released to date relating to the
sale of bellevue
do not reference the impact to bellevue
house terrace and gardens
the access
into the area from the current main
entrance of the park is being sold to
churchill
as part of the disposal site
you can also get into the gardens
through a trampled clearing through the
trees to gain access
but this is not suitable for many park
users
including those with mobility issues
buggies etc
please can you confirm that baba
district council will provide access to
this area of the park
that it will be
being included in costings and confirmed
that public access will remain to the
terrace and steps outside the house
which has which was not included in the
sale
which you have categorically stated that
land outside the red line would not be
disposed of and which is confirmed by
baba district council public assess
accessible open space held on a
statutory trust for the public
thank you
for that i will now uh due to council
halt's absence i'll ask councillor mel
zvazi to read her response thank you
thank you very much chairman
and to miss knight thank you very much
for the question
unfortunately council holt is not able
to join us this evening and he's asked
me to respond on his behalf
as has been agreed previously at cabinet
the capital receipt from the sale of
bellevue house and part of the old
swimming pool site as defined by the red
line disposal area will be directed
towards the creation of a new park
entrance
and in fact work is already underway on
this project
plans for the new entrants new toilets
and the proposed new cafe
will be subject to a public exhibition
later this autumn alongside enhanced
proposals for the park and we will
welcome comments and suggestions at that
time which will lead to the creation of
a planning application for the park and
the new access facilities
i can confirm that access shall remain
to the whole park and in fact our aim is
to improve not just the access but the
moveability around the park for all
users
more details of our plans
re-landscaping will be available at the
public engagement event thank you very
much
thank you guys for mogazin
i would now like to ask
roger young to ask his question
thank you chairman
first of all i must declare my interest
as a resident of hadley
and my questions relate to parking
i note that the strategic parking
questionnaire
with 31 questions is now back online
it still contains typos but i guess that
any of you counselors who have got
around to trying to complete it will
have identified them
it's clearly not been trialled
and tested before being launched or
relaunched
anyone with any experience of
questionnaire design will know that it
is not fit for purpose and i predict it
will get very little response hence my
first question
could counselor malvezi kindly confirm
the details of the brief
given to the designer of the strategic
parking questionnaire
and the target percentage response it is
seeking to achieve
yeah
thank you mr young although your
question is differs to the one that
you've sent in you've submitted so
marginally
okay
because i think your question is one of
many that we've received recently
however baber is keen to develop a
parking strategy that provides a
comprehensive route map with regard to
the long-term approach to the provision
of parking across the district
the strategy is at high level and needs
to identify our parking requirements for
the next five to ten years
to reflect national policy guidance as
it applies to both the future of town
centres and high streets
to recognize the need for sustainable
transport and travel as well as patterns
of demand
ensuring the right level and types of
car parking facilities with the right
controls in place for their use will
help to support regeneration and enable
development in and around the district
town centers as well as in rural
villages
it is important to ensure that shoppers
tourists visitors residents workers and
commuters have access to sufficient good
quality safe welcome parking
opportunities
more specifically the parking strategy
needs to provide a set of deep detailed
recommendations as to the nature of
future parking provision
serving both town centres and rural
villages and how they will function
operationally
the parking strategy is building on work
previously undertaken in the form of the
joint area parking management plan and
the subsequent baber car parking study
report which highlighted the increased
need
for a parking strategy
for the medium to long term
the strategy comprises of three stages
as was published in the timetable and
agreed by cabinet on the second of
august twenty twenty one paper bca
forward slash twenty one forward slash
sixteen
stage one is the investigation and data
collection
this includes our parking strategy
survey which launched on the 31st of
august for a period of four weeks but
has since been extended
the purpose of the survey is to give
everyone the opportunity to have their
say
give their views thoughts etc on what
parking issues are important to them
alongside the survey will be virtual
workshops for targeted stakeholders
again an opportunity to tell us what's
wrong and give their views
stage 2 is the creation of the strategy
this is expected by the end of april
this stage will allow for further
opportunity
for consultation with stakeholders
stage 3 the governance process
has an expected completion date of
september 2022
in summary the consultation currently
underway is there to collect your views
on how parking both on street and off
street is affecting you right now
it is about the places you use already
what works what doesn't
these are spaces that you know well and
will have experience of that
when we would like to hear about it
we will use all that narrative along
with
that which exists regarding future
housing and capacity as well as existing
traffic regular traffic regulation
orders
and all this will assist us to draft a
parking strategy
we will then share this with all
stakeholders for comment prior to any
decisions
thank you mr chairman
mr young have you a supplementary
question
i have indeed chairman
but i'd just like to comment on the
response i've received i'm sorry you
have to ask a question okay
well at the
baylor district council meeting on
thursday the fourth of february
councillor malvizi confirmed that she
had attended two meetings about parking
in hadley and the minutes confirmed that
she said
the steer to us was clear
more free time
and a later implementation date and
if we are not covered free
we will revisit the implementation date
my supplementary question is why has an
implementation date for parking charges
of the 1st of january 2022 been set
before we are free of covered
restrictions
because this is in direct contravention
of the promises given to hadi residents
by this council
i'd like to
respond
thank you very much chairman thank you
very much mr young
yes i would like to respond but i would
like to respond in writing and out of
this meeting thank you
um
the next question was from council
dawson but the question her questions
have been withdrawn and we can now move
to the next item
oh
sorry yeah sorry
yeah sorry i've
jumped it a bit
um item seven questions by councillors
in accordance with council procedure
rules
i refer to the questions in the table
papers
and i would like to invite counselor
beer to ask his question
thank you thank you mr chairman how
could you forget me
right
at the february 2021 full council budget
meeting
we approved the maximum increase in
council tax
and increased car parking charges to be
employed in our own weber car parks
the reason stated
that at the time we were due
to due to the forecast budget position
that a 1.8
million pound deficit was going to occur
this was presented at many workshops and
by
finance officers and cabinet member for
finance
to help balance this position we were
given several options
to introduce the full allowed council
tax increase which we did
introduced car parking charges and
closed the sudbury advice center
i voted against these
being introduced based on the
information supplied at the time we now
have the final 20 20 21 financial
outcome figures which show a rather
different position
we now have a surplus of 725
pounds
so mr german in the light of this
information will the cabinet withdraw
any
withdraw the introduction of any car
park and charges
this will give our town centres of
sudbury and hadley a breathing space to
recover from cove at 19.
this would certainly send out
the correct message to our hard-pressed
residents of baber
and show them that as a council we do
listen to our traders
and the public at large
thank you
to respond to the second part
thank you chairman thank you castle of
here
uh thank you for your question and
before handing over to councilman lvc to
answer the specific matter of our car
park tariffs i would like to correct a
couple of misconceptions in your
question
firstly i'd like to point out that we
provide an access point not an advice
center we've never run an advice centre
in any of our face-to-face locations
this may seem like a pedantic comment
but it is important as it gets to the
nub of some of the criticism of the
decision to move it and i want to
provide a further clarification and say
that we have moved it not closed it it
is still very much open and successfully
serving our residents
part of the reason for the move was that
it would give us savings but it needs to
be understood also that the contract was
due to expire in march and we took the
opportunity to design a more appropriate
service aligned with our customer
strategy and the changing way our
residents interact with the council
secondly i did report when i presented
the budget that we were forecasting a
cumulative three-year deficit of 1.7
million pounds
this still stands and i don't expect it
will improve in the foreseeable future
indeed it may well go further in the
wrong direction but officers are
currently reviewing the figures as part
of the preparation for setting the
budget for next year
the favorable outcome of out turn of 736
000 pounds does not change this because
most of it was due to fortuitous one-off
benefits that won't necessarily be
repeated in future years
we have used this money to top up some
reserves most notably the climate change
and biodiversity reserve and the
strategic priorities reserve but
reserves can only be used once and don't
solve our base budget gap which still
remains
thank you chair councilor vici
thank you
thank you council award um councillor
beer the funds generated from car
parking have to be ring fenced
to pay for that provision
because as you know it is not his
statutory service and currently our car
parts run at a substantial loss
which cannot be sustained in the longer
term
they are solely in need of investment
we are providing new ticket machines but
our car parks also need resurfacing they
need remarking
and crucially improved lighting for the
safety of users
we must have additional income for this
our economy is dependent on tourism
and to encourage visitors to our towns
we need car parks that are clearly
marked and indicating if there is space
many is the time that i go into girling
street car park to find it full but
nothing to tell me if there are spaces
elsewhere
and do i drive around wasting fuel no i
go home as do others
as i've mentioned earlier and as you
very well know provision of parking is
not a statutory responsibility
and currently it is a drain on council
tax
which only forms 29 of our income
and business rates
which is
sixteen percent of income
both of which must fund our statutory
services
we most definitely are listening and
have ensured that we will
still be providing a very generous
one-hour free period with only modest
short-term charges for stays beyond that
we will not be introducing charges until
the new year
after the busy christmas period
however people's decisions on where they
go
to shop
and other experiences are determined
more by the offering
of that location and not on whether they
have to pay a pound for parking
our two towns do very well in this
regard
and we have supported our high street
businesses with a very successful
rollout of the award-winning virtual
high street that now has 150 businesses
on the platform in sudbury and over 60
in hadley
with an accompanying digital skills for
business program
in addition the welcome back funding
provided to both towns will help to put
on local events
enhance the appearance of each centre
and seek to draw greater footfall into
our places
these are some of the exciting events
and activities that sudbury and hadley
have been doing using the welcome back
fund
and there's more in the pipeline
we're working on the town centre's
image their presentation with new
planters and hanging baskets
in sudbury they've used the welcome back
fund
to create town centre ambassadors to
support businesses and visitors to the
to the town centre
a new initiative to have green sundays
which are monthly which are to encourage
new businesses to attend their market
area that support the green agenda
heritage open days over two weeks
earlier this month that had guided tours
and activities to celebrate the heritage
of sudbury
audio trail on the silk heritage of
sudbury
hadley
they've used the welcome back fund to
innovate local
market stall pilot which offered one
stall for a new business for a free
period usually four weeks which started
in july and goes on until december
the stalls are now booked out till
november
they have created a mini tourism info
point for a redundant bt box which has
been received positively they have
created their own loyalty cards for the
town center which supports residents
using the high street and the cards are
put in for a prize once collected once
completed
the prize is a voucher
of the resident's chosen shop in the
town center
we are a council
that also run activities including
kinetic science with open spaces in
bellevue park bowman park and cox's park
we have
pushing out social media on the
activities and supporting the towns with
events
you will know councillor that the date
of introduction for the new parking
charges will be discussed at cabinet in
october
i would encourage you to attend that
meeting listen to the listen to the
debate on that item and of course ask
any further questions on this important
subject
thank you very much
also have your supplementary question
yes mr yes mr chairman thank you
so from the answer from the leader and
the cabinet member you have decided not
to return the
725 000 surplus to the taxpayer and
residents of baber district council
but now instead will you be using this
amount of money
to help pay for the proposed massive
wage increases to our seniors officers
so is it more money for senior officers
and more taxes for baber residents
thank you
i'd like to respond in writing out of
this meeting thank you
thank you
um i'd now like to invite councillor
jameson to ask his question
thank you chair
uh councilman alves you're very busy
tonight
um
although we're fairly lucky in this
country so far the extremes of weather
experience globally this summer giving
increased evidence that climate change
is happening now
as this is our last council meeting
before cop 26 will the member fair
environment advise us and concerned
labour residents if the council were
doing anything to encourage a favorable
outcome at the conference
i realised we're about a small pebble on
this large beach but a litter to the
government would be the very least we
could do
thank you very much councillor
jameson what we are what we have been
doing
is to encourage a favorable favorable
outcome sorry
i'm a bit dry
i should have brought some water in
um
as you know baba committed to tackling
the very real issues relating to climate
change and biodiversity early on in its
tenure
we are just over midway through our term
and your question has very kindly
enabled me to bring
council up to date on what we've been
doing to move the district to a better
natural environment all round that is of
benefit to all who live and work in the
district
now just in case because there are
people who don't believe that climate
change is real it is real
and it's
and the damage that we've done on the
natural world on which we depend for our
own survival is why we need plans but
our plans touch on a myriad of
initiatives some of which are wholly
environmental but many impinge on other
portfolios
for example the well-being
portfolio of
councillor davis
only covers part
environment covers the natural
external environment
we've switched the fuel used in our
waste phrases at freighters from diesel
to hvo
a
certificated fuel made from recycled
used vegetable oil
and
none of it
is grown in fields to be processed
in doing this baber is one of the first
local authorities to so
do demonstrating yet again
that we are leading not following
this will immediately reduce the fleet
carbon emissions by 90 percent
and the council's overall emissions will
be reduced by 25 percent
this fellow councillors is a big step
forward
and as we move forward we shall move the
rest of the fleet to either hvo
or electric vehicles
we've started work on improving our
planning design guide
and are working very closely with baber
planning department and developers to
build back better and greener in line
with government policy
as an example in my home village of long
melford
we've successfully negotiated with
bloors
to have an area as a wildlife flower
meadow running parallel beside the
melford walk
thank you excuse me why
in a couple of years
this will have had a major benefit to
the local nature reserve
the developers are also installing swift
boxes
creating hedgehog runs
bat boxes
which are being made by the local scouts
and it's a way of engaging the community
they're also installing water butts
in every property
so that water consumption on the garden
will actually be rain water as opposed
to tap
we've won funding to put a solar carport
into the car park at kingfisher with
multiple electric
vehicle charging points
and given that we live in a very sunny
part of the country
we will be storing the unused
electricity generated by the solar
panels for onward utilization
i think the planning application is
currently going through
we're introducing new technology into
the kingfisher center to reduce their
energy and water usage by recycling the
warm water in the pool through what's
called a backwash filtration system
very soon we shall see the conclusion of
a mapping exercise that's been conducted
in conjunction with suffolk wildlife
trust
when completed we as a county as well as
a district will be able to see what
nature reserves we have in relation to
each other and how they can be linked to
provide a wildlife highway nature route
all issues that require planning
guidance which we plan to put into the
planning supplementary guide
furthermore by using satellite
technology we've been able to identify
what sort of tree canopy exists in our
district and what types of trees exist
within it
this means that we will be better placed
to plant the right tree in the right
place
we're rolling out a free tree and hedge
offer to parishes
which has created a lot of interest
however in baber we are short of our own
land supply to be able to create
community woodlands but we are working
on it
i think it's very important to note
also that all the trees and hedges will
be locally sourced
we will not import
dutch elm
we need a lot of trees
and hedging which in turn will provide
local employment
towards the end of this year beginning
of next we're rolling out the wildflower
meadow verges
and there is more but the important
thing to remember is that we are on
track
to achieve our carbon reduction plan
and our biodiversity action plan
cop 26 is the 26th
climate change conference
and i expect to see from central
government clear actions
and further support on how we can
accelerate towards our climate change
and biodiversity actions
we will be listening closely and we'll
be sharing highlights of the conference
throughout
my advice to residents
on how they can influence the outcomes
of the conference is to get involved
the cop 26 conference website has a page
on how to be involved but you can do
more than that you can make changes at
home right now
that is and those are the things that
will make the real difference
decide to cut down on single use plastic
try not to waste water
cut down on car use only buy the food
you need
switch to buying from environmentally
friendly companies
switch to green tariffs
these are the things that will really
make a difference if each and every one
of us
committed to them
sadly
some are not
but i believe most
are
thank you very much chairman
a very concise uh response thank you
council jameson have you a supplementary
uh yes sir cheer thanks
just a quick one yeah
um
now let's be tracked now
the environmental task force that was
set up um as part of the climate
emergency
motion that you yourself in the business
focus very much on the getting the
council to carbon zero by 2030
can we now widen the remit of that
environmental task force to look to see
what we can do to help the district as a
whole get to carbon zero by 2030.
i'll get back to you on that
okay
obviously i've got a bit ahead of myself
but councillor dawson has withdrawn her
question
so we can now move to the next item
i refer you to paper bc 21 stroke 13
which is for noting only
which is overview and scrutiny committee
report
i'd just like to add if there are any
questions for council mclaren please can
you email them directly to her as she is
not able to be here this evening
thank you
uh item nine
recommendations from cabinet
uh stroke committees
now item 9a
bc 2114 annual treasury management
report 2021
chairman i would now like to invite
councillor haran to introduce paper bc
and to move the recommendations in the
report
thank you councillor
thank you very much mr chairman
i almost stood up then and then
remembered i didn't need to
it's my pleasure to present this report
which is an over the overview of what we
are have and now are dealing with
the treasury management 20 20 21 out
turn report was discussed at joint order
and standards committee on the 26th of
july
it provides details of investments
performance
effects of decisions taken during the
period
and confirms compliance with the county
with the council's treasury management
policy
the coronavirus pandemic and the impacts
of global lockdown dominated 2021
the start of the financial year saw many
central banks cutting interest rates as
lockdowns caused economic activity to
grind to a halt
the uk government provide a range of
fiscal stimulus measures
the size of which has not been seen
in peacetime
the vaccine approval and subsequent
rollout program are both positives
but there remains much uncertainty
in and around the level of losses that
banks and building societies will suffer
due to the economic slowdown
the bank of england has held the bank
rate at 0.1 throughout the year
but extended its quantitative easing
program by 150 billion
to
895 billion in november 2020
the uk unemployment rate was five
percent in the three months to january
unemployment was expected to increase as
the various government job support
schemes come to an end
we will see
inflation has remained low over the
12-month period latest figures showed
the annual headline rate of uk
cpi fell to 0.4 percent year on year in
february
below expectations of 0.8 and still will
owe the bank of england's
target
more specifically for baby chairman the
council was able to take advantage of
holding additional cash from government
grants received relating to covert 19
until they were paid out to support
local businesses
this has increased treasury investment
activity during the year and has also
earned us a little extra money
the council operated within the daily
bank account limits and the short-term
debt
has increased by 15
and a half million
i think that should be thousands
actually maybe that be confirmed
later the council lent a further 19.3
million to cifco limited
all investment activities undertaken
were in accordance with the approved
counterparty list the council's
investment activities including average
returns can be found at a appendix c of
the report before you
the investment in funding circle has
reduced by 48 000
as unallocated funds have been reclaimed
and existing loans repaid
leaving the balance on the 31st of march
as 166 000.
the council is being compliant with the
upper limits for interest rate exposure
the investment activity undertaken for
the year was done so in priority order
of security and liberty and liquidity
over yields as prescribed in the
treasury management
strategy if you have any questions i
will be happy to answer what i can what
i'm able
if it's a bit too complicated for me um
i may need to phone a friend or even two
friends as i say now so um
as a team we should be able to cover
everything chairman
i'm happy this is the sum of a lot of
work i've tried to just
set the scene and the detail as always
as in the paper
um but it is a result of a lot of work
very careful management
it's a bit foreign to me i normally do
other things i'm not that good with
other people's money quite good of my
own but
it's a true reflection of what has
happened and
i think as we enter more and more stormy
waters as we are now going to um
the audit um committee will come into
its own
thank you i'm happy to pose this for
noting and look for a second to chairman
thank you could i have a second please
thank you
we'll now move to questions
count as
may ask as many questions as they wish
however they must be relevant to the
subject under discussion
and must be a question
anybody question
council busby
yeah i'll keep going off um i noticed in
the the general fund uh the borrowing
requirement has increased from
50.7 million to
71.3 it's a 20.6 million increase that
seems an awful lot in one year only
somebody could tell us what
what the reason for that is please
i think i may need to call in rebecca or
catherine probably be for that one
please
i know the figures but not the reason
so the most significant increase for
last year was in relation to the
finalization of the civco purchases
obviously we were borrowing to complete
the the 50 million purchases during last
year
thank you of course i knew that really
it was just testing the rest of you
thank you council husband
any other questions please
and now just um
well i just apologize to council plum
for not
giving his name as the secular side
counsellor
any other questions
council ward
um yeah we
in this report we show the
separation of the capital financing
requirement between
general fund and hra but when we look at
the the net borrowing um and also the
the total borrowing and the debt we
don't separate that out between
the general fund and hra is it possible
to do that please
thank you for the question yes we can
certainly look to do that for future
reports that's not a problem
are there any other questions
and i shall move to
debate um
councils will not be allowed to speak
will only be allowed to speak once and
for three minutes
and this will be timed thank you
anybody wish to start the debate
uh i'd like to get a recommendation
please
i think what councillor barrett might be
suggesting is that we should move to the
vote i think that's probably yes
okay i'm happy with that
oh councillor hinton seconded
council yes
councilman
thank you i will now ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office to
conduct the electronics
perhaps i've missed something
um here but the recommendations
is just to be noted so why are we voting
thank you
move on
yeah apologize that is for noting thank
you ma council maybe
you're very welcome chairman
um
we have to wait while
they're actually
chairman i'm sorry to interrupt the
meeting and to
take members back to the item however
although the recommendations are worded
in such a way as to say to note
you are actually noting
um that performance of treasury
management was in line with the
prudential indicators
and also
that the councils have complied with the
treasury management indicators for this
period so it is
normal that the council actually votes
uh to indicate that you agree
that those
measures have been complied with thank
you chair
mr chairman yeah in that case why do we
need to vote if
if we vote against it we're not actually
saying anything so you can only vote yes
for this anyway so why do we need to
have a vote
chairman a vote against the
recommendations would suggest that the
council doesn't think that performance
has been in line with the potential
indicators and that the council doesn't
think that you have complied with the
treasury management indicators so
actually
it is possible to vote either way it's
not a yes or nothing vote
thank you emily
so
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic votes please
thank you chair councillors can you open
the vote in the modern.gov app by
clicking the plus sign in the top right
hand of the agenda screen and selecting
attendance and voting in the voting for
this item it will now show in blue
please click on that blue line to open
the vote thank you
you
yes i'm going to abstain because it says
noting thank you
item 10
which is bc 21 stroke 15
capital investment fund
company cifco capital limited business
trading and performance report
2021 part one
and i would like to
i'd like to welcome
henry cook
director sifco capital limited
nigel golda director strategic assets
management
j-i-l-l and helen rumsey
partner ensores along with our own emily
atec assistant director for assets and
investments and managing director for
cifco capital limited
councillors
i would like to deal with this item in
the open part of the agenda if possible
so can i please ask members to refrain
from asking any questions that relate
to individual tenants and the associated
risk
if you wish to ask a question
questions on these details please can
you indicate
and we will move
into closed session at that point before
returning to open session to vote on the
recommendations in the report
i'd now like to
invite councillor busby to introduce
paper bc 21 stroke 15
and to move the recommendations in the
report
thank you chair
i'm pleased to introduce this report
detailing sifko capital's performance
over the last 12 months
and the proposed business plan for the
next 12 months
the business plan is a fundamental part
of cifco's governance and ensures
accountability to its shareholders
i particularly value the contributions
from the joint ons committee in june
they confirmed that the business plan is
robust and they have confidence in the
management of cifco
since its inception in 2017 sifko has
provided baba with 3.5 million of net
income
1.3 million of which was last year
despite the unprecedented challenges of
the pandemic
this is testament to the investment
approach and strong management of the
cifco portfolio since its inception
which continues to see rent collection
rates well above the industry norm
this business plan recognizes that the
challenges of the pandemic are not
behind us and takes a prudent approach
to cifco's financial management over the
next few years
ensuring that the cifco portfolio
continues to provide
income to the council
running at about a quarter of council
tax
to support the delivery of services and
local projects i therefore ask you to
note
in 3.1 and approve in 3.2
thank you
thank you councillor busby
could i have a second
council award thank you
now turn to questions and debate
we now move to questions counselors may
i
counselors may ask as many questions as
they wish however
they must be
it must be
there must be a question
relevant to this subject under
discussion and must be a question it's
not a question
or an inaccuracy
which i'd just like to point out
because at ons the paper came forward as
a noting document not a document to be
discussed so um
we're in the it's in the same position
that we are in here so it wasn't exactly
came it didn't come to ons to be
scrutinized it came forward to be noted
yeah sorry emily please could you
clarify
thank you chad i think um councillor
barrett's point is in regards to the
recommendation that is included in the
report that's presented to scrutiny
which
is normally worded in such a way as
um to note or to be non-suggestive
because of course scree the process of
scrutiny generates the recommendations
so we don't provide scrutiny with
preempted recommendations
you say
it was to be noted
and it wasn't something that could be
discussed
and investigated but
i think sorry chair yeah it was
discussed it it was scrutinized and the
committee did
approve verbally well
if it was scrutinized it went to the
committee and the committee looked at it
but the recommendation on the to the
committee was to note it
okay well let's concede that minor point
discussions thank you
counselor lindsay
is this a question
yes it's a question please yeah
um
the uh
deferment of
the money that
it's
um 1.5 million
being deferred that we're not um
that we thought we were getting and
we're not in the next three years from
cifco
um
[Music]
can i clarify what exactly happens to
that
money if they can't pay it back at the
end of three years
what happens to the money that we are
owed
this is uh if to help people i'm talking
about page
100 and
let me make sure i've got the page right
at page 113.
and i think it's item 12.7
yeah i mean the item 12.7 on page 112.
thank you
is it in the confidential papers but i
mean i can give you the
the intention is for for sifco to pay
the full amount each each quarter and
each month and it continues to do that
at the moment
um all we've done here is to suggest
that
or take a precaution
in case
because of the economic situation we
can't do that what happens is that the
money will continue to accrue to the com
to the council and you will incur in or
cifco will incur interest
payments on that as and when it can pay
it so at the end of the three years if
it's still not
paid the full amount then the interest
will continue
and you the council will get its money
are you happy with that emily
good evening perhaps i could just
clarify so what has been agreed
um in terms of the proposals is that the
deferred income will be paid back at the
end of that three-year period in the
event that cifco aren't in a position to
make that full payment at the end of the
three-year period then that amount will
be added to the existing loans so we'll
be repaid over the longer term um of the
um
the loan agreements but as uh councillor
busby has said there will be additional
interest that accrues as a consequence
question chair
um so
the
the interest isn't being paid now
the extra interest that's all accruing
we hope but we'll get it back at the end
of three years is that right and if we
don't
there's no guarantee we will if we don't
that will be added on to the loan we've
already given cifico
so how much is the loan we've already
given them and when does that when is
that due to be repaid
so the loan repayments um are scheduled
in the report um
it's in the appendices of the the
business plan so it shows the um the
repayments that are proposed the loans
for each acquisitions were for a 50-year
term and the acquisitions were all
bought at different stages so
the remainder of the loan
term depends on when the assets were
bought but they range from um 2017 when
zipcar was set up
through to the last loans that were made
at the beginning of 2020
so in the event that
sifko isn't in a position to make the
full repayment within the
loan terms and yes that amount will be
added to the
loan and spread across that remaining
loan term which will be
probably between about um
48 years and 45 and 48 years left over
that term
thank you mr chairman i'll sit this time
um can you just confirm whether this
will be compound interest please
and i'm and i'm speaking to our officer
here emily attack thank you
thank you and i'll perhaps refer that
question to our finance team um who have
um calculated all of the the interest um
and loan repayment so if i can refer
that to
catherine steele
behind the 151 officer
thank you
thank you chair as i can confirm that it
was compound is why it's been calculated
um thank you uh just to come back well
compound interest on 50 million would be
very nice thank you for baby district
council and we can build as many houses
as we like as in council houses and we
can do whatever so thank you very much i
shall look forward to compound interest
thank you
it's not compound interest on 50 million
are there any other questions
um
is the council
at the moment receiving a cash flow
advantage to this operation
as opposed to um
just an accumulation of a capital sum as
the cifco are not in a position to pay
the cash over to the council
so again just to clarify cifco today has
made full debt repayments to the council
in accordance with the original loan
agreement so the business plan proposals
and
set out
are to provide provision
and and some sort of prudent financial
management and as a consequence of the
the pandemic that has had an impact on
um cifco's operations but in answer to
your question even with the um deferred
payments yes the council does receive a
net benefit from the civco operations
again i can refer you back to
our 151 officer
who can confirm that from the council's
perspective
any other questions
well there isn't i shall now go to
debate
uh as the questions are finished we will
now move to the debate councils will
only be allowed to speak once again for
three minutes and this will be time
thank you who wants to start a debate
counselor lindsay
um just to say i think i'll probably be
voting against this um
just because i don't
really agree with the business plan that
seems to be dependent on us
deferring a loan for however long they
want us to defer it for for the amount
that's convenient for sifko
um with no guarantee that we'll get it
back so
anybody else
anybody else want to be in this debate
oh councilman crawl
um
i think every time this comes up and
it's becoming a regular routine manually
uh having followed it from its
inception all the way through
every single scrutiny committee that has
scrutinized this and yes they have i
know that because i've watched every
single one of them including the one i
wasn't doing
every single time
it's been scrutinized it's been taken
apart put back together again
and every single scrutiny committee
composed of members of all groups
have
endorsed the business plan year after
year
and they have presented it to council
which has also endorsed the business
plan year after year and the
income that we've gained has gone up as
was forecast despite some very tricky
circumstances in the last 18 months
i don't think we've any choice but to
endorse this ourselves
it is a robust business plan and the
concerns about the deferment of a
payment under the circumstances
deferment of payments in these cases is
not abnormal and i think there's quite a
clear case being made
for uh proper prudential arrangements to
be made for that payment repayment to be
brought back to us and should it not be
brought back to us for us to further
recover with interest compound or not i
don't think at the current prevailing
interest rates compound interest is
going to make a great deal of difference
but the fact is it's there and it is a
credential operation and that's why i
think scrutiny have endorsed this year
after year and i'd be happy to vote in
favor of the emotion
councilor mavery
thank you thank you very much mr
chairman um i think my um colleague here
has made a few sweeping statements um
which do not include me and i was part
of the ons committee at that time when
this was
discussed a few months ago
one question that i didn't ask and i
don't know if i can ask this question
but somebody i'm sure will tell me
which is if it's compound interest what
are we what percentage are we putting
that on
that
no that'll be catherine
yep two percent is the figure that's
being used
thank you
yeah thanks chairman
echoing councilman crore's comments and
the fact is cifco is providing us with
regular guaranteed income
um the amounts are in section 12 of the
report and and elsewhere
but you've got to remember that we are
increasingly dependent on this money our
investments which cisco are
probably four-fifths of our investments
in total
now account for 14 of the council's
income
this this is regular income that we are
using to provide services to our
residents it's making up for
the loss in government support we don't
get the revenue support grant anymore
we are increasingly having to stand on
our own feet
in order to provide services to our
residents
council tax and business rates as you
heard from councillor malvisi earlier on
in total come to less than 50 about 45
of our income
investment income is necessary
sales fees and charges income
is also necessary
these are the facts of council finances
we can't do without cifco it is doing
the job it was designed for and it's
doing it very well
thank you
thank you chair it worries me that we
are deferring repayments after only two
years of this investment yeah we've got
50 this investment is for 50 years
before we get our money back and we're
already deferring repayments
uh can i come in chair we're not
deferring payments yet uh
so far all monies that have been due
have been paid it's only a precaution we
hope that we don't have to defer it but
there may be an opportu
an occasional rises this this business
plan
the money has already been invested in
cifco this business plan is about good
management
you can't vote against
a company doing good management which is
what this is about it's about
managing the the portfolio it's about
managing the clients it's about working
with the clients it's about
sustainability it's about debt
collection
that's what this business plans about
because we've invested everything
vote against it and you're saying well
we don't want the company to operate on
it with good management i mean it's
ridiculous
thank you thank you councillor busby
is everybody finished with debate
council about
i mean i agree with councillor busby it
might be a very good business plan but
uh if the business model is not
sustainable
um then however well it's managed it's
not sustainable and it will go down the
swany because eventually you will
actually have what a day of reckoning
where you have to realize your reduction
in your asset base
because you will end up having to sell
it so yes it might be extremely well
managed but basically if the business
model is not good
it still doesn't work um which is
you know a counter argument i think
and a cautious one
but uh yes we're not disputing that our
officers are very capable and our board
is very capable but if the actual model
is not a sustainable model
it doesn't matter how good you are
managed you cannot
with the market going down as it is and
your asset base going down you will
eventually have to realize those losses
which will come back to the shareholder
which will come back to the district
council
just a warning
but that's rather a gloomy uh prediction
of the future
you're already
thank you the market experts people who
understand this far more than you or i
uh anticipate
that we will be back up to full value of
the portfolio within 10 years
thank you council busby
is there any any other further
further thing of full debate
uh to go council buzzfeed do you wish to
add anything
other than what you said
thanks
thank you
thank you council busby i will now ask
corporate manager governance and civic
office to conduct the electronic vote
thank you
thank you chair councillors if you go to
a modern.gov app and open the voting it
we're now showing blue for you to cast
your vote thank you
abstain thank you
thank you
chair that is 40 um
sorry yeah that is 16
oh
sorry
i'm nearly there
and we are now their chair so it's
eighteen four
four against and three abstentions so
chair that
and four extensions
um adding council maybe into that sorry
thank you
that is carried in
don't need to go an exclusion
um can i thank our guests from pacifico
for being present and i i trust that
they will uh
ensure our
further investment uh profitably thank
you
now go to item 14.
vc 21 stroke 16
joint well-being strategy
and i would like to invite councillor
davis to introduce paper bc 2116 and to
move the recommend recommendations in
the report thank you council davis
thank you
i'm delighted to present the very first
baba well-being strategy this evening
and will be as concise as possible
this is a high level document developed
by you as members
council officers
key partners such as the ccgs public
health and other key community
stakeholders
the strategy focuses on identified needs
which are and will be dealt with
specifically in the associated delivery
plan
the well-being of our residents in baber
is probably the most important aspect of
our roles as district councillors
as everything we do
and the decisions we make haven't have
an impact on health and well-being
the vision for this strategy will mean
residents will have the best possible
conditions for good well-being and have
lives that are healthy happy and
rewarding
developing a well-being strategy has
enabled the council to set out strategic
vision and approach to support the
well-being priorities of its local
communities
understanding our well-being priorities
will also enable us to make most
effective use of our resources
addressing the well-being of our
communities has really been more
important than at present as we live in
the shadow of a global pandemic
well-being put simply is about how we're
doing as individuals within communities
and the society
it provides a holistic view of people's
lives taken in not just health but our
opportunities engagement and success in
other areas of life including social
civic economic and
and the built and natural environment
it is well recognized that the broader
determinants of health are particularly
important ensuring healthy and a happy
population
and there are also types of well-being
issues over which the councils have some
control and influence for example
stimulating stimulating our local
economy
managing our environment
developing and managing our homes or
providing leisure facilities
the strategy therefore does not
duplicate the well-being impacts already
contained with our economy housing
environment and community strategies
there are other strategies
that these other strategies will however
be reviewed to ensure well-being
outcomes are being optimized through
those strategies and performance in
relation to those aspects will be
included when we are reporting on our
performance in respect of well-being
the strategy cites the 10 measures of
national well-being developed by the ons
but offers for national statistics which
organizes nationally surveyed and
gathered data into different areas of
life affecting well-being
we have adopted the 10 areas with a
focus on personal well-being relations
health and local communities where we
live and what we do with our time
and the focus will be on enabling
families to lead active healthy safe and
independent lives and manage their own
health and well-being
all communities to have sustainable and
inclusive places and spaces which
maximize health and well-being
opportunities and benefits
and a health a reduction in health
inequalities
as the strategy spans the period to 2027
our long-term outcomes are supported by
a set of shorter term outcomes that will
focus on the next two years
and are accompanied by more detailed
objectives which is set out in the
strategy
and where it makes sense to will be
delivered in partnership both external
and internal stakeholders
while developing the strategy
we haven't stood still
and have delivered a number of projects
and supported many of our communities
throughout the district
for example the chill chat and play
support personal health and well-being
mental health of new parents and mums
which are referred through midwifery
services in the hadley and sudbury areas
active schools a two-year project aimed
at schools with the least physically
active pupils
active well-being you've already seen
that in long melford lebanon and
throughout baber bilderston
and now in this year we're going through
east bergo shotley and holbrook and i
had the pleasure of being at one of
these active well-being events recently
absolutely superbly put together
by our officers and partners
there's also the free activity activity
sessions
in our parks led by an instructor at the
recreation grounds behind the stevenson
center in great corner
so sessions included boot camp and hit
high impact intensity training
hadley food programme also needed to
identify by food banks sessions learn to
cook recipes which are simple and with
the within budget from the professional
chef at fork restaurant in the high
street in hadley and this helps reduce
loneliness and social isolation and they
get a slow cooker at the end of it as
well
great machines i'd like to thank our
officers um especially vicki mosley and
lead in the whole team you will have
seen today simon landing also sent out
slides which you can refer to
i commend adopting the wellbeing
strategy
as recommended in points 3.1 3.2 and 3.3
to ensure our community community's
needs are well understood
resources are allocated in the best way
and supported targeted to those that
need it most
thank you chair
and it's a well
worth well-being strategy thank you
um
can i have a second up please
councillor mccrory thank you
now move to questions
and degrade the questions
as many as you as you wish however they
must be relevant to the subject
under discussion there must be a
question
thank you
you'd like to ask a question counselor
hinton
thank you mr chairman my ears pricked up
when uh
my home villages burkhart was mentioned
but i missed out on exactly what was
actually being proposed to happen there
because it seemed to get blurred in all
sorts of other things
yeah i'm happy to answer that um
eastbourgel the the constable country
practice um and
the local council i understand as well
were invited to take part in the health
and wellbeing
activities
sessions run by active suffolk and the
ccg
um and baby as well
and if you haven't had it yet it will be
on its way and if you need details i'll
ensure sue carver gets those to you
any other questions please
counsel barrett
as part of the wonderful well-being
program uh are you going to introduce
the free swim again
that's certainly the plan yes um
we did have a
cut down version of the free swim during
the summer um within the activity
program that was put together but the
the wider range in free swim is
certainly on the cars to return as soon
as possible
are there any other questions
i shall move to debate
um
you will have three minutes
each council will have three minutes to
debate this
and
just
just at the end of that we will then
take the vote for it thank you
very ambitious uh strategy and
i think it's almost too ambitious that's
my concern i think there are many things
in there that we can't control
unfortunately
many things that we would like to
control but we can't so
um
i almost have a horrible feeling that
we're kind of setting ourselves up to
fail but
the the journey
is a good one
yeah thank you it's a good point and
that's why we're working very closely
with various partners as i mentioned in
there the ccg public health centers
other key holders we can't do this by
ourselves but we have a wonderful
communities team as you know and they
liaise very well with these and so
that's why we're able to put together
such an ambitious strategy that will
benefit all the baby residents
council maybe would you like to ask your
question
mr chairman i think my colleague
councillor lindsay was first
no i i i thought there were no
debate points i was asking to move to a
vote but um i'm happy too
debate
i was debate yes sorry councillor haron
thank you chair um
i'm normally a cups three cups full sort
of person but this does worry me the
country is
um slipping down the pecking order we're
no longer the richest country we've
ended up being about 10th and
in some parts of my ward we're a million
miles from this
there's become a real sort of
poverty and
rural transport seems to
even in oxford two
buses we used to have ten everything is
going
the opposite way
you know i can point
to places where there's no help at all
and this is wonderful but um
we need to get the basics help to people
first i think this is sort of all apple
pie and very nice
but we're moving further away from it
and while ambition is good
we need to have realism as well
[Music]
derek very nobody talks about partners
but when i look around
the police are
almost non-existent the county council
can't seem to manage a rice pudding um
looking at all the signs everything is
total
deprivation it's going in the wrong way
and while having all these ideals are
nice
i make the point again let's get the
basics
up a bit food banks are
biggest expanding growth industry and
people are um skinned and worried and um
that is my concern this will fit well
with some people but there's
we used to have the have and have nots
but now we've got the downright
impoverished as well and
that is a concern of mine chairman
thank you for listening
um thank you very much chairman um i was
interested
to look at this and whilst
uh sorting out at home i actually found
this which is a joint health and
wellbeing strategy for suffolk
refresh
2016-19 you want to have a look at
will yeah
and
what
whilst i don't decry that some of these
things are worth
reviewing and reiterating
um i don't actually see why baber is
doing a separate one
when we have that anyway suffolk county
council are doing it anyway um and and i
just
and i just wonder if there is
too much of a crossover and perhaps
um we may have spent some money on
things that we didn't need to
um
i
will comment on the swim ming
i have spoken to tom barker on several
occasions about this
the free swimming i am not opposed to it
but it needs to be directed at the right
people
um
i can
tell you that
the scenarios that i've been given which
is the free swimming yes the children go
in for free however depending on the age
of the children the parents have to go
into and it's the parents who cannot
afford
the actual adult fee so i hope if we are
doing this it is targeted at the right
people i.e
if it needs to be means tested that
someone has to show a card that it is
free for the whole family and not just
the children because we're not reaching
the right the right people
i totally agree with free cookery
classes
myself my colleague councillor ayers
have offered to do this in our
capacities in
previous lives not just as parents and
grandparents
but for myself in particular through
business we are more than capable to
give free cookery classes to
some parents who may think that they
cannot cook or even perhaps because they
can't cook
and we've always been very happy to put
this forward so i think some of these
things could be done in house without
being
put forward in such a document and i
could go through and the one thing that
i had to smile at considering i am a
carer of someone with dementia is that
we will be supported
i certainly look forward to that one
because if you've been through the
minefield of registering yourself as a
carer for someone who has dementia
i can assure you it's all yes yes yes
they come to the door and they go no no
no
so i that's the one thing i look forward
to and if my colleague councillor davis
and i can talk about this in the future
and we can actually work out a proper
strategy
for looking after carers
i would give that a gold star
thank you
council davis would you like to reply on
that one do you think you'll be waiting
until the end yeah
councillor barrett melanie barrett
thank you jim um
as
cancer davis says it is a high
level document but i think the proof of
the pudding will be
in the um the delivery plan um when we
see some detail on that so that i look
forward to that but um
while we're we're trying to to build
that sort of um that state
um
i hope we can
um look at um how we support our own
residents dealing with antisocial
behavior because i think that is a great
source of
um
uh um trouble in in people's lives when
it when it's actually affecting their
them where they live
um
and it was so
refreshing for some of us in and over in
discretion yesterday to meet officers
who were
uh employees by a baber who who
presented um
to us about uh dealing with anti-social
behavior i'm thinking about in
particular tendency tendencies not not
the wider sort of issues in society
um and because i think that might have
been something that we needed to
to get right in baba i think we we have
perhaps allowed um those sort of
problems to just be moved around
um and and then forced it on
unsuspecting new new neighbours
um so um i hope that this this action
now will will help that that move
council award and then councillor joe
osborne
yeah
thanks chairman um just just a quick one
on antisocial behavior we
we have beefed up the the team here and
our response to anti-social behavior
quite considerably with peter watson has
been brought in um and a lot of that is
on the basis of uh the feedback from the
stella marist inquiry
a lot of the
feedback there is was directed at to
many agencies um not so much beta but
nonetheless we're making sure that
the multi-agency response to some of our
more complex cases is far more robust
and kicks off
far sooner and
we are seeing some some uh
some reasonably good
um evidence that that is working now so
we are making huge gains and huge
strides in anti-social behavior so um i
don't think that's about uh
you need worry about that it is a
significant uh issue we know about that
um but i do agree with what you said the
delivery plan is is where the proof of
the pudding will be with with this but
i'm sure that we will have a delivery
plan that that will will be flexible
enough to allow us to do the things that
we we really want to do as a district
which we can do and which we can uh can
afford it's going to be a very flexible
delivery plan um
that will allow us to
uh to pick and choose what we can
achieve over the course of a number of
years
and
we'll be working as has been said with
with many partners active suffolk of
course as councillor davis has already
mentioned so
i think that um yes the strategy is
ambitious
but
we will be able to deliver and we will
be able to live deliver in partnership
with others
on an ongoing basis to to realize that
strategy because it is going to be
essential for our residents thanks
chairman
thank you castle
councillor john osborne
thank you mr chairman i was also going
to respond to councillor barrett's
concerns about antisocial behaviour i
know it's a concern of many councillors
in this chamber tonight but council
award has responded very well so i won't
duplicate what he said um i welcome this
strategy thank you councillor dave it's
a really good one i think we have to
have aims to aspire to because otherwise
where do we go
you know we need we need to do that
um
it also aligns very much with the
housing team's aims and aspirations so
i look forward to working in the team
working
with your team to to bring
about the success of a delivery plan
i must say i do have a concern
about the contribution from our partners
because the delivery plan is very much
dependent on the police mainly and
suffolk county council and my experience
of suffolk county council to date
in regards to
housing has been a little bit not too
good if i would if i were to say that so
i do have concerns there so i do hope
they bring up their game
um to ensure that um baber and
suffolk are successful with this
well-being strategy so thank you very
much
council osborne
council beer
um thank you mr chairman um well as
you're aware i've been on about
anti-social behavior for a long time i'm
pleased to hear that
you're attempting to do something um i
think the point that councillor
jan osborne made regarding the county
council
hopefully they will get their act
together better i and understand that
and accept that but i think baby needs
to as well we take far too long we talk
far too long
we try and um do all sorts of things
with these people and the rest of the
residents have to suffer some of them go
on for years
and and we do know that
we've been successful on one that's
taken a lot of time and money and effort
and counsellors involvement as well as
officers
and
at the end of the day they they just
tend to ignore because they know they
can get away with it for longer because
we come back and we try and have another
little talk we send in people to clear
up gardens cut hatches and all sorts of
things
and then it all comes back again and
this annoys other residents because they
feel that we're we're sort of trying to
do too much and not
solve the problem so i would ask that
you get this task for together and that
you do
strengthen
tenancy
rules because i think that's where a lot
of it goes wrong
but there's a lot of anti-social
behavior that i'm afraid
really doesn't get sorted and it's far
too long mr chairman to solve it thank
you
casa beer councillorathe
yeah thanks chairman um i wanted to
actually highlight a
different theme
and just so that you can reference it
it's on page 11 of the strategy which is
page 237
of the agenda papers
and it's um under the where we live
theme
and i'm just gonna read out you don't
have to find it i'll read them out to
you
it's
people will have areas in which to live
that are safe clean and pleasant
people will be able to live without fear
of crime anti-social behavior hate or
exploitation
people will have access to homes that
are affordable well-built sustainable
attractive and in tune with their
surroundings
people will be part of cohesive vibrant
and active communities that embrace
identity and heritage
people will have convenient access to
services
and people will have access to natural
spaces
and i'm sure you can all guess the point
that i'm making here and that is our
approach to planning and the decision
decisions taken by councillors will all
have a significant impact on whether
these things will be achieved and point
out of course that our new jlp
supports their delivery
thank you thank you
council plum
thank you chair i'd like to recommend to
this council that we accept this report
with open arms as an experienced parish
councillor i can see that i want this
team coming to my parish very soon
as a
district councillor all i will look
forward to is them succeeding in
something that everybody's at the moment
ducking away from thank you derek thank
you the team i look forward to seeing
you in clemson
thank you um council davis is there
anything you wish to add
quite a lot
and and in fairness it's in response to
the questions which i think were
absolutely um relevant and on point
um
i'll start with the asb because
obviously that is an issue and it's
something we you know we we're already
working on to to try and achieve
um
the council award mentioned about the
appointment of peter watson and the in
the asb team fastly experienced officer
and he and he's going to spearhead this
along with the rest of the team but we
do have and you're right it takes too
long but you know we are tied as you
know by the law regulations and
everything else like that so we're going
to try and get there but some of the
things we already do um
we have noise abatement notices yeah
which we will
enforce um notice notification or
seeking possessions serve to address us
depending on the behavior of tenants and
just like you as beautiful as shotley is
we've got a couple of people that you
know
and possibly might want to prefer live
somewhere else and and we've also in
terms of the victims well they came from
corner actually but that's a different
thing
i wasn't going to mention that but yeah
yeah you can have them back anytime um
but
in terms of supporting the victims
you're absolutely right that is hugely
important and there's lots of ways we do
that obviously there's victim support
and restorative justice which we we
leave to to the courts when we can get
them there
um
in terms of um funding i'm sorry i it
might have been yourself jan that said
this about getting the partners to pay
up
you know kathy nixon is not a lady you
say no to very easily and she's helping
to to spearhead talking to those
partners at the highest level and then
her and the rest of the team make sure
that we are getting the support and
brian you're absolutely right we're in a
really dreadful situation so we need to
tackle it we need to meet it head-on and
do everything we actually can to do that
and this strategy goes to that we have
to be ambitious okay if we reach for the
stars we might just reach the moon but
we're going to try everything we can and
and stephen yo i'm sure as you know sue
culver and others will come
to glensford and that's the same for
every ward member if you've got issues
let us know and our team will try and
deal with it um
and the strategy yeah absolutely this
strategy has been tried elsewhere the
soviet county council one now is pretty
much out of date and one of the first
things that was said when we put the
strategy together it can't be just a cut
and paste job from somewhere else
the team worked very hard to make sure
that this was our strategy that
encompassed everything that the baby
residents needed so it is bespoke in its
own way but of course the problems are
not necessarily bespoke they're
widespread so we're going to tackle them
head-on as well
i don't think i've missed anything
i don't know yet
i'm afraid you have spoken already once
on debate
yes chairman i'm aware of that and thank
you for letting me have another bite of
the cherry i think of this paper
i've been looking at it and you can see
the sort of disquiet around by some
quite experienced councillors i think
maybe it's lacking in what i would call
um
citizenship and responsibility and if we
achieve all these things we've almost
got to have a
different mindset we need
better people to do this better
counsellors better politicians better
statesmen and we don't we don't tend to
have that at all we need people
i'll tell you what i think we need
people people capable of starting a
revolution
and change the way we do things and
change the mindset of certain people
i could start at tomorrow council about
it but um that's just the way
i'm feeling it needs a different mindset
we're all behind you don't think we're
again you we're all behind you um none
so more than me but you're starting from
quite a long way off from where we need
to be but i wish you luck and um
yeah by all means vicki email me and i
can say a lot more
thank you councillor yes
thank you chad um i would like to bring
out about the access for
those who are not able to use a computer
and i know east suffolk they have a
scheme where they um actually lend um
the elderly or those at carmel is to
help them and i think going through kobe
as we did those that could facetime
their families
and that sort of thing would be good so
i'd love if we could maybe introduce
teach people how to use these skills
because they're so important thank you
yeah thank you thank you and it is
something we have done in the past in
terms of um you know both in sudbury and
in shortly with the uh the pop-up so i'm
sure that's something that councilman
mccraw will deal with within his
portfolio
thank you councillor davis
that concludes the debate
um
you've added what you wish to add
so
thank you very much
we'll now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair the vote is now showing
in blue if councillors would like to
cast their vote thank you
counselor maybe can i take your vote
please
members
members please
um chair the votes are 24 votes four
and two abstentions thank you
members um
thanks carrie um i will now
have a
comfort break for 10 minutes
dead on half past you see
so can you please be
back here within 10 minutes please
coming back so so soon thank you
thank you chair just to to let you know
in case you're wondering our senior
leadership team have left the meeting
whilst this item is being discussed
because obviously they have a pecuniary
interest in the matter
however if you um do require the chief
executive to come back to answer some of
your questions we can get him back in
the room so um if if um if suzanne and
michelle can't answer the question we
can get the chief executive back in
thank you
thank you jan
item 15 members
bc 21 stroke 17
paid policy report
uh members of lct as jan's already
mentioned have left the meeting at this
point
first of all i would like to welcome
michelle kirk
uh director east of england local
government association and susan hughes
head of hr and od
who will be delivering a short
presentation after council award has
introduced his report thank you
i would now like to invite council ward
to introduce paperbc 2117
and to move the recommendation
recommendations in this
this report
thank you chair i'm pleased to introduce
report bc 2117 the pay policy report
councillors i'm not going to speak for
too long to introduce this report as it
is more important we hear from our head
of human resources suzanne hughes and
from michelle kirk of ilga who has
produced the independent report that you
will see at appendix b of the council
report
as has already been mentioned the chief
executive and the senior leadership team
have left the chamber
but the chief executive
in israel's head of paid service will
come back for questions should that be
necessary
before again leaving before any debate
and vote
now turning to the report itself i i
know some councillors have expressed a
view in advance of today that this
matter has been rushed to council
i therefore thought it would be useful
to set out a brief chronology by way of
introduction before handing over
the salary levels for our assistant and
strategic directors were last reviewed
10 years ago when we first started
working jointly with mid suffer
the levels that we put in place in 2011
have therefore stood the test of time
it was highlighted in the risk section
of the pay policy report that we debated
in march this year that our salaries had
fallen behind the market
however no changes were proposed at that
time
despite not having needed to carry out
senior officer recruitment in the
previous two years
officers were hopeful that they would be
able to successfully recruit to the
newly formed assistant director for
communities wellbeing post within our
existing page structures
despite extensive marketing and strong
interest for this four-way shared role
it became clear when discussing it with
potential candidates that many did not
consider the salary level appropriate or
competitive with similar or their
existing roles
14 people applied but the majority were
deemed lacking in sufficient experience
or potential to be interviewed
as a result no short listing or
interviews were held
based upon this feedback ilga were
commissioned in may to conduct an
independent review of senior pay in
order to determine whether and or the
extent to which the council's pay scales
are uncompetitive
michelle kirk's report and
recommendations are contained within our
council report tonight and in a moment
i'll hand over to her to take us through
her report
finally though before i hand over i'll
simply refer all counsellors to
paragraph 5.2 of the report on page 261
of the agenda
which draws directly from our pay policy
this is an uncomfortable issue for any
council to have to debate but we need to
be guided by the words of our policy
in the context of managing scarce public
resources remuneration at all levels
needs to be adequate to secure and
retain high quality employees
but at the same time needs to recognize
that this is public money
i'll now remove the recommendations 3.1
to 3.4 call for a seconder and then hand
over
thank you chairman
thank you michelle and suzanne please
could you deliver your presentation
thank you members and thank you for
inviting us to join your meeting this
evening i'm michelle kirk i'm the
director at the east of england lga
my background is in hr specifically in
senior structures and senior pay i'm
also an advisor to the national
employers on pay matters
i work very closely with the 50 councils
in the east of england 39 of which are
districts and i'm currently advising a
number of those councils on the same
issues that you're facing here in in
weber
so may i have the slides please
so as councillor ward has told you
ilga was commissioned to undertake a job
evaluation exercise and a paying grading
review
of your senior pay levels and that was
in connection with the failed
recruitment process that's been
been mentioned by council award
in the context of undertaking that
review there are a number of things that
i was asked to take into account
the fact that you have a holy shared
workforce but two sovereign councils
does present a complexity
and does create some difficulty in
recruiting it also is a is an attraction
for some candidates
both councils have
strong values with high aspirations and
objectives and i'll come on to those
shortly
and in order to meet those ambitions and
those objectives you do need the very
best staff that are available in the
market
and so i was asked to consider that as
part of the brief
i was also given information around an
all councillor workshop that was held in
may
that looked at your key challenges and
asked to take that into account
okay
would somebody be able to advance to the
next slide for me please
it's not working
isn't technology a wonderful thing
towards me
is that a little better
i've never been accused of being too
quiet before so i apologize
um
so in terms of the context that i was
given these will be familiar to you
because you will have been at the um all
council work all counsellor workshop in
may but just to refresh your memory we
were looking at uh coverage recovery
the economy in the two districts climate
change and biodiversity which is a
relatively new area for all councils
planning
which i know from my own experience
living in one of the districts has been
an issue
housing including social housing
building safety communities support of
well-being and you created the new
director role to address that and
specifically the health reforms new
health landscape future local government
funding
customers and using data to drive
decision making next slide please
as has already been said by council
award i work for ilga so this was an
independent review from that
from that perspective i have no
vested interest in any of this but i do
sit outside of the two councils and
because i advise across the region and
across the uk i was asked to undertake
the review
the complexity of working for two
councils um has the direct result of you
needing staff who are agile who are able
to think quickly and creatively on their
feet and understand the nuances that
that working for two councils brings
both councils share an agenda but you
also have your own agendas
directly
and the need for highly skilled officers
is shared across the whole of the public
sector and particularly in local
government
current arrangements that you have
haven't been reviewed since 2011 as
councillor ward pointed out
and we are in a very competitive
recruitment and retention climate and
i'll say a little bit more about that at
the moment
but in undertaking the review i did have
a very close eye on good value for the
public purse for the taxpayer and there
is a direct link between having high
quality staff that can make a real
impact in your council and the salaries
that you're able to afford in order to
attract those staff
so i started looking at some
benchmarking may i have the next slide
please
i want to say a little bit about the
challenges to recruitment and retention
now this is very specific to senior
staff so staff at tier three in your
organisation but also tier two
and chief executives and professional
staff so i want to say at the moment
this is where we are with the landscape
previously pre-covered one of the unique
selling points working in the public
sector and in local government was the
family-friendly policies the ability to
be flexible in terms of hours worked and
the ability to really make a difference
what's happened during covid is that the
private sector quite frankly have caught
us up
they offer agile working they offer
hybrid working they offer working from
home in a way that hasn't been available
pre-covered
so the private sector has become a
competitor for us in a way that it
hasn't been able to do previously
previously the the choice was more money
in the private sector or a better
work-life balance if you want to work in
the public sector that's gone
um to a large degree
the other thing that shifted is that
employees now expect that better quality
work-life balance
but they're able to demand it regardless
of which employer they're in employed by
you already know you've had difficulties
recruiting at an ad level that's likely
to get more difficult
in some ways you're a victim of your own
success your officers come with good
reputations you come with an ambitious
agenda
your staff will be on the hit list for
several headhunters
ilga does headhunting we don't pinch
staff from our own councils you'll be
pleased to know
but other
head
hunting companies will have your staff
on a target list
pay is not the only issue as i've said
ambitious agenda work-life balance
they're important but in the end pay
will pay will
will play a really significant part in
somebody's decision to come to you or to
stay with you
and what you already know is where you
are carrying vacancies you're not able
to move your agenda forward next slide
please
so as part of my role i've done a major
piece of benchmarking across all of the
councils in the region looking at skill
shortages senior managers have come out
as one of those areas where we're having
difficulty recruiting and retaining
that piece of work was commissioned by
all of the chief executives in the 50
councils
um
what i've already said is i'm working
with other councils elsewhere looking at
the same sort of issues but bringing
them up to market standards we're not in
the business of leapfrogging each other
around salaries so that we're
perpetually trying to raise salaries at
the same time to increase levels at the
same
place in different councils that's not
what this is about this is about
bringing baber up to the same level as
other councils
so i was asked to make some
recommendations for the senior team
and i did that by evaluating each of the
roles to assess the weight and value of
them and then taking those results and
setting them against the pay bench
marking next slide please
when i looked at the 39 district
councils and the complexities that they
face the most appropriate comparators
appear to be those that have a shared
workforce
so babe mid suffolk shared workforce
broadland north south norfolk shed
workforce in both of those examples
their sovereign councils
east africa and west suffolk have been
included for comparison purposes because
their salaries were set at the time
before they merged
and you can see from the overview of
senior salaries that weber and
mid-suffolk are a long way behind the
market
next slide please
data that was used for pay bench marking
is 2020 salaries may have shifted
slightly since that benchmarking was
done
and the reason i've concentrated on the
three comparators that i've shown you is
because they're the most similar to you
um baber is behind the market in all
levels of seniority so chief executive
director
and with your ads in particular
and your salary for your chief executive
is the lowest in that type of authority
that i've shown you previously
the difficulty with having a low salary
for the chief executive is it depresses
all the salaries further down so it
depresses your salaries for your
director
and for the ads next slide please
having a single director
in an organization of this size is
unusual
there's usually at least two
where there is a single second-tier
officer in district councils it tends to
be a deputy chief executive and
therefore that's the um that's the
benchmark that i've used typically those
roles are placed at a minimum of between
100 and 100 5 000
your ads have less access to senior
staff because you've only got one
director and the chief executive that
means they have to be more strategic and
more corporate in their approach
and they tend to have corporate
responsibilities that otherwise would
have accrued to a director role
they tend to be more autonomous and have
contact with members partners and
stakeholders which isn't typical of a
tier three role elsewhere
next slide please
so i've shown you the comparators
already um they are in the report so
i've shown you the comparators for
shared arrangements or previously shared
arrangements
um i've shared with you the difficulty
in recruiting at the moment and the
difficulty in recruiting in shared
arrangements presents a particular
challenge
your salaries do not reflect the weight
of the roles that you're recruiting to
or the roles that are currently held by
your ads
you've had to use market forces
supplements in the past at this level
and you may have to do so in the future
the difficulty with market forces
supplements is what it's telling
candidates is you haven't got the salary
right
the salary is at risk because it has to
be reviewed regularly and some
candidates will not go for roles where
they think part of their salary is at
risk
next slide please
so this is the proposal going forward
it's in your report it brings you to the
same level of similar organizations so
chief executive
salary
proposed to increase to 140 to 160 000
strategic director 100 to 120
and the assistant director 78 to 90 000
and suzanne will take you through what
the impact of those changes might be if
you were to approve this proposal
grab the next slide please john thank
you
um so in terms of suggested net steps
from our uh perspective if this is
agreed uh full council is that our
existing staff would move to the closest
point and progress over time and our
recruitment would continue in the same
way that it has done previously that
would be based on skills and experience
that's our usual practice
next slide please
so in in terms of costs at the start of
the year we carried out a senior
leadership team review
where the second strategic director post
was removed and a new assistant director
for communities and wellbeing role which
is jointly funded with our ipswich and
eastern west suffolk ccg partners was
introduced this resulted in a cost
saving of 67 000 pounds and i'll take
you through on the next slide a little
bit more detail around the costs as
outlined in the report next slide please
okay so that's quite uh it's quite small
for me to be able to see that here but
i'll take you through it so um the
ongoing savings of the removal of the
strategic director is shown on the top
line of the first table in that
breakdown
line two the line below shows the saving
in this year
and that's as a result of our
failed recruitment for one of the better
words to the assistant director role we
haven't recruited and as a result of
that there is a cost saving there
and line three shows the additional cost
of the elder recommendations each year
so if you to total those up over the
four year period that would take you to
a figure of just over 60 000 pounds and
the way that we've worked through those
costs
is that it's based on where the
individuals currently sit within their
own scales and what the additional cost
would be of them moving to the new
scales assuming good performance
the first
row there which is this year just shows
a six-month saving so you'd need to
double
that cost as well and that figure as i
said is just over 60 000 pounds um but
if you add the first column you double
the first column that would take you to
just under 70 000 pounds so if you look
at the the second the second table which
is directly under that
that shows that will take away the
strategic director cost which is 33 and
a half thousand pounds all of these
costs which are shown incidentally are
per council so if you take that away
then the overall cost for that four year
period
will take you to a total cost at the
bottom of 35
982 pounds
that is a net cost so on top of that
cost you would need to build in national
insurance
and also
pension contributions and we would do
that at 33
and that therefore would give an overall
cost of 47 thousand eight hundred and
fifty six pounds as detailed in point
nine six of the report
could i have the next slide please
so in summary i think the findings from
the uh report that's been produced by
michelle
are clear that we've fallen behind in
terms of comparative salaries we do
believe it needs to be addressed not
just for the longer term but also in the
immediate term we have two critical
assistant director roles to film we have
the joint assistant director role for
communities and wellbeing which is a new
role and we also have the assistant
director role for corporate resources as
catherine steele is retiring um in april
of this year if next year so if we can't
get those salaries right then we won't
be able to recruit the right quality of
candidates that we need to be able to
deliver the agenda
but also for future succession planning
of our roles as well
and that's my final slide
sorry
did i say counsellors my
apologies my apologies if i said that
i'm not sure why i said that but we need
to recruit to assistant director roles
to apologize because we have the two
resignations
and we have to we have the one
retirement and we have the one new role
apologies
can i thank uh both you both for your
presentation
uh it's very good and uh
deliverable i hope
i will now
move to questions
of the counselors and once again
they can ask as many questions as they
as they wish however
must be relevant to the subject under
discussion and must be a question
thank you
any questions
hello newberry
councillor very bad thank you
um
hello suzanne and michelle um i've got a
couple of just quick questions um based
on on what we've just heard
um
i wondered
probably directly more michelle um were
you asked to give or did you give your
opinion on
any different approaches other than
uh
handing out more cash
um as this this this was just based on
one recruitment
failed exercise this year
so i wondered if you if you could give
us uh
you know your recollection of what what
happened at that time
yes if i may um
i was asked to look at the package the
recruitment package that you have is
very
conservative with a small c
you don't offer lease cars you don't
offer private health insurance
thinking about was the job description
was the job design correct was the level
of post correct and those sort of
approaches that you you know more
creative thinking around the problem
i wasn't asked to comment on the content
of the roles as i understand it the
chief executive worked with the senior
team around that and that's why the new
ad role was was created suzanne may have
more to say about that i was asked about
recruitment methods and we discussed
that and we did talk about the overall
employment package
i think my conclusion based on the
benchmarking and understanding the roles
that are available in other councils was
the configuration is probably right but
the salary is well behind the pace of
the market
um
and um
the figures we've seen we've been
presented with
they're based on the current year aren't
they um really and and you know what
what costs will be
um
but as we know
those members of staff will then be able
to progress each year by an increment
um
and there will there's three bands in
each person's pay and i'm doing this a
little bit so for everyone's benefit
because not everyone is an hr geek like
me
um
so they will progress each year
and can you tell me how how many pay
points they could progress in a year
um if they met their targets so they
would only uh progress one pay point so
the the calculations have been done on
this year but the yoga recommended costs
are based on if they are progressing
naturally to the next point so there is
a spinal point that they can move to on
an annual basis based on performance so
they will start um
for those who they will start at the
nearest point in their salary so it
depends on their current salary as to
where they will start but the
progression will only be once a year it
will be an annual progression and the
costs were due that were devised were
devised taking into consideration that
people would automatically progress to
the next pay point so those costs
actually take that into consideration
and so therefore all those members of
staff because there's only three bands
in each
now there used to be five so they would
have taken five years to get to the top
what you're proposing now is that they
were to only take three years to get to
the top of their salary scales yeah and
i think michelle you might be able to i
mean i i don't understand why you did
that so michelle keep the five points
yeah i think michelle you can answer
that question um articulately if you if
you cut around the pay points
so five years is unusual now for pay
progression
because the the normal approach is that
when somebody is originally appointed
they tend to go on the bottom pay band
unless their skills and experience
dictate at a higher level so they come
into the role usually not quite the
finished article
they start to progress in terms of their
development over year one in year two
they probably have reached full
competence in the role and in year three
they will be adding value because of
their longevity of service
the difficulty with longer pay bans is
it can be indus indirectly
discriminatory to women who tend to have
shorter periods of time in the workplace
and men have longer periods of time in
the workplace men are more likely to
reach the top of a pay band with five
points than women are
well
only five years worth of employment
that's not that significant i don't
think
thank you
and to address the issues about um
attracting the candidate to the the post
of uh communities and well-being
you could have offered a flexibility a
flexible payment could you not a
supplementary payment
like a recruitment retention allowance
so the uh information that we had from
everybody who had applied for the role
irrespective of their uh capability was
that we were offering around about 15
000 pounds at least under the market
rate
we could have offered a market forces
supplement yes
but actually by doing that as michelle
alluded to earlier you are restricting
the time that you would keep somebody in
post because market forces supplements
um are only um relevant for two years
and they have to be reviewed so people
will see that as you know there isn't
that uh that the role isn't evaluated at
the right level
and actually after a two-year period
their salary or their market forces
supplement could be taken away so
whilst we can add it it isn't something
that would attract the candidates that
we were looking for
okay
um
thank you i haven't got further
questions at the moment
um i now have john hinton please
counselor john hinton
thank you mr chairman
what is the presume you looked at the
impact of these raised salaries higher
up the scale
on what it did to the rest of the
workforce is everybody else going to ask
for an increase as its cap has been
taken away at the top and what's that
going to do to the total wage packet for
the for the council
um
sorry
and secondly
did you do a comparison
uh with
councils other than the ones in suffolk
because we do butt up to essex and
tendering in colchester our right smack
bang on our doorstep
how do we compare with them because they
didn't feature in the report at all
so so i can answer the first question as
best as i possibly can and then i'll
hand over to michelle you can answer the
second part of the question so in terms
of individual salaries across the
organisation we have various different
pace spine points within those bands and
we regularly review those job
descriptions so people can move from one
pay band and one grade to another
so if we don't anticipate it would have
that that same effect but when it comes
to assistant directors and strategic
directors and ceo there is no way that
we can reevaluate those roles and take
them to a next level because there's no
other level to go to whereas with other
people within the organization we can do
that and we regularly do do that
if we feel that there is more breadth
being added to a role or we feel that
the role is being underpaid
for the actual role that they carried
out they carry out
and in terms of the the benchmarking
hopefully that answers the question i'll
hand over to michelle
so the benchmarking that ilga did took
into account all 39 districts in in the
east of england
the reason i gave you the three examples
that i did as they are the most
comparable roles it's the complexity of
working for two councils that that's the
issue for you
when i talked about the single director
model that data is drawn from across the
whole region because it's unusual to
have a single director either in this
model or in a in a single council
environment and that's why the strategic
directories role is compared to the dce
role the deputy chief exec role that we
see elsewhere so yes i did look across
the whole of the region and in fact
looked across the whole of the uk in
some areas
and the levels that you are paying for
the rates for the roles that you have
isn't comparable to other areas of the
region and that's why i hinted that you
might be vulnerable to some of your
staff being head-hunted
council robert lindsay please
i i
actually councillor hinton kind of
aren't asked my question for me but i'm
not
i'm sorry to to be a pain but could
could you repeat your answer because i'm
not quite sure i followed it it was
about the
the the
what will be the impact on the staff
below
the senior level if we
you know on the entire
um
cost for the council
so i don't think we can ever say that we
wouldn't review um everybody else's
roles because the environment that we're
in at this moment in time i think there
is such scrutiny on pay and benefits um
and i think one of the things michelle
talked about was our vulnerability to
the private sector and there is that
vulnerability whilst we have um
whilst we pay a good pension within the
public sector uh we don't pay any of
those large bonuses that we pay in the
price that people pay in the private
sector i've come from the private sector
to to work within the public sector so
i'm very aware of the bonuses that are
paid along with car allowances and along
with medical insurance family medical
insurance so i i can't ever say that we
wouldn't we wouldn't have some kind of
impact across the organisation but what
we do have within the organization is
that people have various different bands
that they're paid to within their own
grade and there are lots of different
grades within the organization so you
know we people can move up those bands
if we feel that they need to and we
regularly review all of those roles
anyway to ensure that we're paying the
the right market value for the roles
that we have
what we haven't done is we haven't
looked at senior manager pay for quite
some time
um you know 2011 was the last time that
we looked at senior manager pay
obviously i think um
arthur chavonia's
salary was reviewed when he first came
into role about four or five years ago
but the rest of them since 2011 haven't
been reviewed and we do regularly review
our salaries across the patch
so hopefully that answers the question
yeah thank you and this is to the hr
director
i appreciate these slides and your
report and your presentation are
prepared well in advance now you
mentioned that there were two vacancies
to be filled for ads one we know
obviously has got time because she's not
retiring until next year but the
community's in health well being posed
has that been filled
so we have filled that on an interim
basis um but but the the um the
conversations that we've had have been
around salary so it is an interim we we
couldn't recruit at the current salaries
that we have so it is an interim basis
yes but the um the salary is paid for
from three different partners yeah it's
paid yes it is so it's split four ways
and twenty-five percent baby 25 mids
african then two to other partners as
well so yes it is a four-way split and
finally how many other vacancies need
fitting urgently
within the organization at the senior
level at the senior level we have that
that position
and we also have the position for the
assistant director for corporate
resources which we'll need to start
recruiting to very very quickly
um i think michelle will be able to
explain that um recruiting for section
151 officer at this moment in time is is
really difficult to do
we did have a previous resignation but
that has now been retracted at assistant
director level
that's okay
thank you jeff
thank you for your presentation um
i know we've only looked at the east
anglian pay scales
but
what would it be the equivalent in
greater london or kent or sussex
could we sort of lose our um people
because they'll be offered a much higher
salary how much higher are they so it's
the first question the second was do we
offer um expenses for removal
adjustment if somebody does come here
how do we
deal with that thank you
yeah so could i ask sorry the second
question was that if people are looking
to relocate
was that the question okay so we
currently have a policy um that offers a
package for relocation should we want to
offer that out to people if we were to
looking to attract to the area however
that policy is under review at this
moment in time as we start to work more
remotely
then you know there is that attraction
for people to work further afield
because they don't have to travel quite
so much so we do have a policy
and we we will pay for removal costs and
also storage but as i say is under
review at this moment in time
so i'll pick up the london salaries
point
um local authorities in london are
different they're unitary authorities
essentially
and because of their geographical
location they tend to offer much higher
salaries but the configuration will be
quite different in a london borough to
the sort of officer cohort that you have
now
there are some similar roles planning
for example
but some of them will also be quite
different because you don't have
children services you don't have adult
services here so
it's slightly different
thank you mr chairman i've got two
questions the second one you may have
maybe for debate and you can tell me
when i get to that one thank you
my first question is on your slides
and um it's difficult to try and say as
you said but i did note somewhere
challenges identified and i think you
said going forward
well when i looked at them and trying to
read them they were all challenges and
things which i would have expected
that the
officers are already doing or are you
saying that if we pay this additional
money
we'll get more
of these
challenges identified going forward
it seemed to me like they're already
doing it so
so
they're not challenges going forward
could i just ask for some clarification
do you mean the list of um challenges
that were identified by members as being
the k key priorities going forward well
they came up on your screen long list of
bullet points yes they were the
priorities that members identified as
your priorities going forward so so
then
by paying any additional extra money
isn't going to improve those challenges
going forward because they're already
doing them
because you made it sound like they were
going to be
yeah so those were the challenges we
were going to pay this money we'll get
this extra
input from them no those were the
challenges that were identified and i
think that the point that michelle was
making was actually in order to be able
to deliver those challenges we would
need the right skill set within the
organization at this moment in time we
haven't got all of that skill set within
the organization and we will struggle to
recruit that skill set if we were to
lose anybody with the current salaries
that we have
thank you that was the question
my second question mr chairman was and
that may be for the debate so i'll just
ask you i'm not sure um the cost savings
efficiency savings referred to in the
document
um so
so it could become
cost neutral
uh every year or in the first years of
introduction
um surely if we're going to do this
efficiency saving
shouldn't
shouldn't isn't this the wrong way
around shouldn't we be doing that now to
get the efficiency savings and then
saying whether we use that money to help
pay for this
so the situation that we're in at this
moment in time is that we have two
vacancies that we have to fill and we've
recognized that we're not paying the
right salaries to be able to fill those
vacancies um yes we have to find um
the the efficiencies but actually until
this is approved if it is approved and
until you're in agreement that we can go
ahead with this and that might not be
the case um you know we we
we can't find those efficiencies but we
know that we will be able to make those
efficiencies
but we haven't identified exactly where
they are at this moment in time this is
purely a recommendation at this stage so
from a financial perspective i think
that's probably one there was some leap
of faith
mr chairman yeah i think that's probably
when our chief executive
would be able to answer in in better
detail well it's a big leap of faith
then thank you
thank you freedom
and chair just to before we go any
further we are fast approaching the
guillotine can i have a proposal and a
seconder to extend the meeting to
conduct the remaining business on the
agenda
please thank you
and can i have a vote consensus vote all
those in favor
thank you very much thank you
thank you very much mr chairman um my
question is the salary that the salary
points that you are proposing in the
recommend or for the recommendations
um that doesn't actually include the
full package does it it doesn't include
what the cost will be to
the council for pensions and i see other
benefits
it doesn't but the cost in the slides at
the end identifies that cost overall so
the cost that is in the report would
talk about how much it would be over a
four year period when we talk about
salaries we never advertise salaries
with the on costs on top so the current
salaries that we have at this moment in
time are purely salaries when we go into
the financials in terms of the budget
then we would always put those on costs
on there but at this moment in time
we're looking purely at salaries as
opposed to on costs
if i may mr chairman
thank you
um
but i think the issue also for members
here
is the fact that someone may think oh oh
okay well perhaps they do deserve a bit
of an increase and then find out that
the cost of the council is even more
because of the pension contributions etc
etc etc
and so
i i actually think that we need
the full value
or i would to agree to this
so the full value is identified in the
costs in the additional costs um in
terms of calculating the salaries we
would normally just look at salaries but
if we put an extra 33 on that that's how
we'd get the on costs on top of both the
current salaries and the extra salaries
but the costs which are identified the
four year total actually does include
those costs so the 47 000 includes the
33 on costs
no i'm sorry
um you you've you've completely you've
completely lost me because i thought
that the
the
slides that you were showing us were the
savings
not the actual costs there were savings
in the first chair if you look at and
the end in column four that actually
shows costs has identified it i think
it's 9.60
well perhaps you could tell me what the
figure is then please
sorry which figure
the the actual the actual cost over a
four-year period
the cost the actual the additional cost
over the four-year period would be 47
856 pounds and that does include pension
and national insurance contributions
the additional costs i'm sorry uh
well i must have misheard because i
thought you were actually saying these
would be the savings
perhaps i'm the only one perhaps other
colleagues agree with me
so thank you but
i i will not be agreeing to this thank
you
yeah thank you
uh two two points if i might um chat um
uh the first one just want some
clarification if if i may thank you i
think you said in your presentation that
a low paid chief executive depresses
wages of directors i think i think
there's a point that you made so um but
the good thing about um uh public sector
is is that the uh all of these pay
scales are public documents um
uh so it might be a point for debate but
i mean i'd just like to challenge that
if i may and just just get some
clarification around that because
um if i look and i've just done some
basic research across a number of
councils locally but if i look for
example at colchester according to their
statement of accounts for 2021 their
chief executive earned 106 000 pounds
but their ads were slightly better paid
than ours but between 78 and 87 000
pounds whereas at braintree they had a
much
higher paid uh chief executive at just
under 150 000 but their ads were between
60 and 74 000. so um so the statement
that the low paid chief executive
presses
wages doesn't appear to ring true so
that that's that's point one
um but then if i may just ask question
um check on page 271 of of your report
um at the top there it says ee lga has
recently surveyed councils on salary
levels tiers one to four the historical
data is contained in a report submitted
to the region's chief executives
surely that report should be available
that that must be material to the
decision that we're taking this evening
so so i'm just questioning why that
report hasn't been made available to
councillors who will be taking the
decision thank you
i'd be very happy to share the report
with councillors if you would like to
see it
i've picked out the pertinent areas for
you
because i was asked to compare like with
like so similar roles to similar
councils with similar challenges and
that's what i've done but i'd be very
happy to share the report that went to
the chief executives if that would be
helpful to you
thank you chair um
i can see that certainly there are
arguments for
the proposals for the senior
appointments
where i would like a bit more clarity is
coming back some of the questions that
were asked earlier
about the impact throughout the
organization
it's not just about roles and moving
people up to different pay points
we have a multiplier
that has effect from senior
salaries all the way through to to other
levels
and i think members might like to know
what the
the ultimate
cost impact could be across the
organization as a whole
given that we're looking at this over
the next four years because you can't
really just do something with the senior
salaries there has to be an impact going
a bit further down it's not that i'm
against it i just like to know what what
the actual cost implications might be
thank you
good evening
um i've just got a couple of things um
one was uh you said there hadn't been a
pay review since i believe 2011. um
although i believe you said half i had
one 2015 or 16.
um is is that saying then that there has
been no pay rises or has there been a
percentage
each year a pay rise for those officers
and
also
um
where councillor as was talking about
different areas of the country it's a
bit like saying we could poach someone
from newcastle or liverpool isn't it we
can't really
that's uh geographical
people get paid different money from
different areas of the country so
really i don't see that has anything to
do with it at the moment because
you could almost be poaching from an
area which doesn't pay the same wages
perhaps this area
um just asked and have members of staff
being given uh wage rises on a yearly
basis
yes so so everybody will receive the um
njc negotiated pay increase um on an
annual basis but actually the the salary
makeup and the spying points hasn't been
reviewed for assistant director roles
and strategic directors since 2011. 2011
and the senior the chief executive
salary was looked at and reviewed um
when he became when he came into post
but yes salary salaries have been
increased as they would be normally but
actually the actual review of the the
makeup
hasn't been since 2011.
thank you for that
the only reason i asked that is um
obviously
i'm just talking about people in normal
jobs
whether they're working in a factory or
they're working uh whatever job they're
doing there's a lot of people out there
at the moment who haven't had pay rises
for a number of years not not not
uh for makeup
okay
okay i've asked
so thank you chair um i'd like to ask
some questions about paris 6.4 to 6.7
of the main report
which deals with our pay policy that we
agree every year about the multipliers
because somebody did refer to the
multipliers am i
correct in thinking we have multipliers
currently set at eight
seven and five
times the lowest member of staff am i
correct in reading this that proposal
here is though that we'd be going over
um
eight point f we'd be reaching 8.5 of
the multiplier or our lowest paid
employment for the chief executive
that's correct but the other two were
actually underneath the scale of seven
times and five times
how would we presumably have to change
our pay policy there yes we would
okay that's basically the point thanks
yes thank you um
yeah i was just actually trying to work
out the sums on between tables one and
two
and how you actually get that savings i
think of for the costings i think i've
got it
worked out
but it's um so
just clarify that the overall cost over
four years will be
900 or
something yeah something to that effect
okay
and that's um but we're making savings
as we only have one strategic director
and rather than two correct
these are numbers but um
what can you tell me if you've got it
worked out what sort of increases are we
talking in percentage terms if you could
please
and i was probably political but the
headlines in the papers are going to say
pay increases of a percent uh voted
either way could you could you clarify
that please it would depend on on the
role um to be fair they're not going to
be the same salary increases that we get
as part of the njc so they would be in
excess of 10 percent
thank you
counselor melanie barrett would you like
to come back
thank you um yes i mean echoing um
councillor mayberry's concerns about the
cost being absolutely clear to us and
what we're agreeing to
um i've tried to do my own calculations
because i really couldn't
understand the tables and that former
and the way that was presented i thought
it was a bit a bit mysterious and a bit
bit difficult for a a lay person to come
and come and look at because there's a
lot of assumptions in there
um so my way of approaching it was to
say what's the difference between what
this year ceo would have had and could
get in future and that is 22 000
increase a year isn't it
what the
strategic director
currently gets and what they could get
in the future that's 24 000 a year extra
isn't it
they would move from where they are
currently to the
lowest point on the scale
it might not be 22
but in three or four years time they can
achieve that
they wouldn't but they would move up in
um if we were to review it they would
need to move anyway so you know they're
at the top of the scale at this moment
in time so we might have to look at
market force supplements as well
only if you feel it's necessary
people can just stay at the top of their
salary scales and not have a
supplement but we do feel it's necessary
because we've fallen quite quite largely
behind the rest of the market well
that's a decision that we will have to
take on board isn't it
um so the assistant directors pay
um it's 8.5 people
isn't it for the whole council before
dividing it it's mid-south again and
weber it's 8.5 times 16k
if they were to be on the top of their
salary scales in four years time and
that is 136 000. now of course that is
for both councils so that's got to be
divided and that is with on costs
which are 60 000.
um that's 242 000 for both councils and
that's a staggering figure it's only 121
000 for this council so that that that's
that's um
that's fine
um
now it's whether you agree that we can
offset that against to a post that
disappeared almost two years ago
we're talking about a two year gap when
since we've had a strategic director so
can we really say that that is now
relevant to bring it into the
picture
with also in that year we recruited a
new
assistant director um you're striving to
debate now well
i may be um but i've had to have
clarification on on those those figures
so i was um
uh sharing councillor mabry's uh uh
point that we absolutely have to have
clarity on what this will cost is in
three or four years time
and i don't think we've got that with
these papers at the moment
i i think based on the information that
we have at this moment in time those
figures are correct
and then that will be the last question
uh we need to go into debate
thank you chairman
i'd like to know what was the reason for
the ad resigning
and what did you have to do to persuade
them to stay
um
i can certainly articulate as best i
possibly can but i think it is something
that that's quite personal so um you
know whether the assistant director
would be happy for me to have that
dialogue in a public environment um i
don't know but basically she had been
offered a more senior role
um with a different council
i think the distance for her
was
a
possibly something that she took into
account at a later stage after she'd
been offered but i also think the fact
that we have an ambitious agenda is
something that has persuaded her to stay
and because she's very passionate about
doing the right thing for baby and also
for mid suffolk
that was the rationale um that she gave
us i don't think she was um
i think she wanted to stay with us
but i think that's something that that
fiona could could answer
for you herself
check and i just remind councillors that
we are in open session we are not to
talk or discuss personal um
wages we need to stick to posts please
thank you
now
go into debate
[Music]
your counselors will have be allowed to
speak once for three minutes
and this will be timed
thank you
you always love to start the debate
okay
thank you very much mr chairman um my
biggest concern over this is the
perception from our residents
um we've all been through um a lot over
the past couple of years
um and i think for residents to see that
we're as a council we're suddenly
spending more money
on salaries i think will
probably give the wrong impression um
and for that
i
i just don't
just don't agree with it at this time
it's a bit like the car parking charges
issue
you can't do the wrong thing at the
wrong time thank you
i hadn't expected to be this quick
um i think our ads and chief executive
deserve as much money as they can get
they do a fabulous job however
i can't in all consciousness vote for
this
and the reason is because the gap
between the the top
and this isn't a slight on arthur or the
chief exec or any of the ads at all but
that gap the 8.1 or 8.5 as it would be
is just extraordinary at this time so
melanie managed to get a percentage
figure of let's say
it's more than ten percent that's more
than ten percent where the officers have
had last year had a one percent pay
increase
you know um the the gap at the very top
is going to be 30 000 pound
that's that's a new officer that's
that's a that's an officer you know that
that could be having a job or more
people getting more pay rises and that's
between the top and the and the junior
officers the ones in the middle are also
going to be and i heard the word
depressed if you like here because it
will be squashed
i just think it's wrong and and as has
already been expressed you know look how
is it going to be perceived among our
residents
we've
you know
someone asked about free swims early on
we couldn't afford them last year you
know um and car parking charges i
believe that we should introduce car
parking charges but what the first thing
someone's going to say
and i know this from public perception
is oh we're you know
we're losing our free parking we're
going to increase parking charges to pay
for a chief executive cell increasing
salary not evenly salaries increasing
salary
so um i'm afraid i'm sorry i i won't be
voting for it
it doesn't matter if it's ring fence
it's still that gap and that perception
thank you cheer um
[Music]
yeah uh i just want to pick up a few of
the points that people raised um i'm
grateful to council mccraw
for crystallising for me what it's all
about which is the
the uh um and his colleagues made a
similar point is about the the ratio of
the top paid to the lowest and we will
have to change our what we're
essentially saying we have to change our
executive pay policy
to allow the people
the highest paid people to have an even
more out proportion pay than the lowest
pay
um
the
uh um
um
counterfraser
was asking about the percentage increase
um i've done the sums just taking the
midpoint from where they are now
to the midpoint of the range
of where what they're asking for
and it's
25 or 26
for each of those tiers it's 25 increase
for the chief executive 25
for the um assistant director and 25
sorry 25 percent assistant director and
25 for the strategic director plus or
minus 1
um that is a
huge increase for people who probably
already amongst the highest paid in this
district highest paid people in this
district the average salary
in weber i've just looked it up is in
2021 was 31.1 k it's the average salary
that's lower than than other districts
interestingly it's the lowest paid
district in the county
but you know maybe there's there's a i
won't go into that but maybe there's
some reason for that um
because if you've got a job near the
coast it's maybe it's more pleasant i
don't know people could command our own
celery
um
so i think the thing we've got to look
at
is the effect not just the cost of this
measure but the effect
on the morale
of the lower paid staff what's it what
are they thinking when they're seeing
people effectively saying well we move
in a different stratosphere to you yeah
we we um we deserve this massive
increase because
we're we're sort of brighter and better
and we could any moment be poached off
somewhere else
and the staff that left it we
desperately need more staff at a lower
level at planning and in housing in all
those departments we need to we need to
get that right we need to recruit people
there first so i'd like to see a proper
review of start of staff pay at all
levels before we give a massive
rise to just the most senior well-paid
ones thank you
oh thank you mr chairman um well there's
a lot more cleverer members with figures
in this room than me and i've listened
to all what you've been saying thank you
yes i agree with you
and i've listened to all what you've
been saying um
and it boils down
to me
from the point of view that this is
morally wrong
to suggest such a high increase
to senior staff who are already on high
wages
they
perhaps may not have had their base
amount increased since 2015
but they've certainly had inflationary
increases along with everybody else
when and where they happened
but
for
our
um
[Music]
leader and cabinet to even go along this
road of suggesting this in these
difficult times
uh to the general public out there lots
of the people
don't earn as much as that we're
proposing to give
one particular
member a increase
of sixteen thousand pounds i think it is
between both councils i mean that is a
colossal amount of money i i don't think
i ever earned that when um i was started
out working and uh
lots of people today are finding it's
very difficult they're losing some
national benefits very soon which
is very unfortunate and i don't agree
with that um i don't agree that we
should pay this high wage to a selected
few members of our staff
albeit that they're very good
and increase car parking charges put up
council tax
and and then we turn around and say to
the public oh well we've done all that
um but we're also going to pay all these
uh senior officers this additional money
it's morally wrong mr chairman and i
hope members vote against it and i'll
take this opportunity mr chairman to ask
for a recorded vote
where you called out the names thank you
right there's lots of them
sorted
thank you
councillor simon barrack
and then i'm going to conclude with
councillor
arthur oh sorry alice is in my crawl i
do beg your pardon amsterdam
thank you
there's a couple of things that worried
me uh a comment that uh when somebody
gets to the mid level of the thing they
they've got average competency
well i'm hoping if we're paying 150 000
pounds for a chief exec we've got more
than average competency
um
i think we're going
look you can be morally
think what you like
this is a simple case of supply and
demand
if you've done economics it's a case of
if you want something you have to pay
for it now
we can take a moral standard to take the
higher ground and say
they're going to pay them that kind of
money but when we run out of staff and
when we don't have the top people
we will stop performing
that's the issue i don't want to pay
them anymore
but i'm not certain you've got a choice
however i do think that we have to
assume that if we increase
the top levels by twenty-five percent
according to robert then we've got to
assume that the rest will go as well
because it would be unfair for the
people that are actually doing the job
to not benefit from a
pay award as well because i think
they're
just as short and scarce supply i mean
we can't get bin men we can't get
housing people we can't get you know all
these people so we've got to look at
their salaries as well and i kind of
agree with robert we ought to look at
the whole thing rather than just this
one or two grades
but whatever we do it's a short term
issue what we're doing here i'm more
concerned with the long term we should
be looking at
what can we do to increase supply
because if we put our pri our salaries
up
we're not increasing demand
uh increasing supply we're just
increasing the demand you've got to
tackle the problem of supply and that's
not done by increasing wages it's a case
of training
careers
education and starting at a much earlier
stage and let's thought was something
about the government as well saying that
they got the same kind of problems so i
think it's a bigger problem
but we have to remember if we don't
pay the right kind of salary we won't
get the employers
uh council mccraw first i'm sorry uh so
it's councilman crawl
uh
simon barrett
claire varthy and council john ward
before
what has actually highlighted here today
is quite interesting
so if you look on baby's own recruitment
positions available
there are more recruitment and positions
needed in the planning department
planning offices are very short that's
where we've got that's where we've got a
real shortage
as opposed to the hypothetical
senior leadership team where we haven't
got any vacancies actually
because we haven't got any vacancies
we've got one person going in
six months whatever
time
the other thing that slightly worries me
on this
we have a process of budgetary
responsibility and bringing forward a
budget
and we've suddenly been i i think we've
been so
bulldozed
into this position
we should be doing this as part of our
normal budget process which is
identified it comes forward we then look
at it and overall budgetary position is
then there because i don't have a
problem
in paying
very good people very good salaries
within the overall budget that we set at
the annual february meeting
to get this bulldoze through now
is one i think shoddy and it should
never come forward like this we've never
had a chance to really look at it and to
have some
online workshop about it i thought which
most of us didn't go to so i think about
four people went to it i think is poor
so i actually feel that
the process is wrong
and as i said really we should be
looking at this in a better way so we as
a council we set a budget for our chief
executive to deliver the services that
we require at the one point in the year
and that's his job to do it not halfway
through the year saying oh sorry we
haven't got it right
that's not how it works it should work
in this organized way which is how
councils work they're not fast moving
and actually the fastest moving report
i've ever seen was this report i've
never seen a report come to full council
as quickly as this it was like oh we
might have a council meeting bang it's
on the full council agenda
um
those are my observations for what
they're worth so i think we should go
back to being a proper council and
actually doing it by debate and actually
doing it at the february meeting when we
have a full council if they want to pay
themselves more money that's fine but
within the total budget that we set as a
council
macro
thank you chair
um i'm going to disagree with you there
councillor barrett um i know
no you're terribly surprised the first
thing i will say is this is an
independent report produced
by the east of england lga
um i'm i'm speaking at the moment thank
you
thank you pardon i'm talking for myself
now the east of england lga are
are independent of us as a council and
they're also independent of any council
operation
and this has been benchmarked with
appropriate measures and most
importantly south norfolk broadland
which is a shared council similar to
ourselves
and there's a lot of complexity here but
let's just take a few things
from the report and all the papers that
have actually been read all the way
through
three point one three point yeah the um
recommended multipliers our policy
states eight
seven and five and this would be 8.5
6.7 and 4.7 something like that
almost within our multipliers we would
need to raise one to 8.5
we haven't carried out a review of our
chief executives pay for five years and
for the other levels we're talking about
for 10 years and actually the costs are
surprisingly modest given the fact we've
taken out a assistant director role and
we are effectively making our assistant
director a deputy chief executive a
position we previously
got rid of
uh we have a slightly smaller number of
senior staff than most councillors most
councils so it does not going to add up
to that greater degree
the risk management in the report shows
the high probability and the bad impacts
when we get scores of nine in risk
analysis we should be worried that's the
red zone
the interim costs um
well if you compare the alternative
to
not getting decent staff at these levels
and also i might add losing stuff who
could have gone to these levels but are
going somewhere else because they're
being taken away they're being poached
the cost of a interim for a year
can be a chief executive level and
that's just for a general uh lower level
interim interims one interim is going to
cost you more than a chief executive we
don't like interims we've said that many
times
now i'm going to support this you don't
can't call this morally wrong this is
the real world we need to pay the
labourer worthy of their hire or we
won't have the decent laborers and if we
don't do this now i fear we'll certainly
have to do it in a very short while
but at that point we'll have lost a lot
of experienced officers and that will
have told on our services across the
council so i think we're being
short-sighted
if we go against this
thank you uh councillor mccraw um
councillor arthi
yeah i'll be really quick um
councillor busby picked up most of the
points that i was gonna make um i have
got a question though and i'm not quite
sure who can answer it
what would happen um this is a
joint staffing so what would happen if
mid suffolk and baber came to different
decisions
will it influence your decision
it might do if mid-suffolk are going to
have to pay the extra cost
would you like us to get
awesome questions
i wanted to ask the the two that
presented that they shot off after the
question so i didn't get the opportunity
but
we i do know that we are paying already
what i don't know what they call it top
up
saturn
market forces supplements to our staff
already because that's the only way we
can keep them so they're already being
paid over
their salary grade
well there you go if
you can either accept it and put it into
their salary or we can have it through
the back door
um surely that should have been
something that that should have been
given to us
something that should have been given to
us in the paperwork which actually shows
that this has just been rushed through
we haven't had all the details can we
can we complete now i'll have i have the
chief executive
would you like yeah
councillor artie would like to ask you a
question
question is we have joint staff with
mitt suffolk what would happen if
mid-suffolk and baber came to different
decisions on this
i'm not sure i can directly give you an
answer that one depends on how you vote
and obviously how mid-suffolk will vote
it would leave us in an interesting
position and it would certainly leave us
in a difficult position because exactly
as you said you have a joint workforce
the reality of how we actually operate
because it's easy to say we have a joint
workplace but the reality is that some
staff are employed by weber
some staff are employed by mid-suffolk
but all staff are reciprocally shared
the other way and we've never had that
issue in the past because we've had
single joint pay scales that was one of
the first things i suspect both councils
did when they first started working
together 10 years ago was to sort that
issue out
so that you didn't have that issue
it will depend entirely how you vote
tonight now mid-suffolk vote and then
we'd have to look at it as to whether or
not mid-suffolk would be able to pay
that on its own i can't see why they
would do that
that would seem an unusual thing for a
council to be willing to to pay for i
suspect that would come with uh
conditions if you like i.e we pay for
our proportionate share um but i think
fundamentally it starts to make things
quite messy
is the non-technical answer and so i'm
not sure i can give you a definitive as
to as to how that would play out because
i suspect it would also be some uh
additional conversations between leaders
between politicians to see if there was
some some middle ground
it's not the most helpful answer but in
all honesty it's not one that we can
directly give you a detailed answer to
if there's no other questions i'll
for the obvious reasons i'll depart
again but i won't depart to you soon if
somebody else is going to ask me to come
back in no
we have just um if clive has finished
i've just got um council award to summer
been putting our hand up sometime
i oh
part of uh to join the debate because i
didn't actually speak in the debate
45 minutes
and that would be the
the end of it and we had to get the
guillotine on the on the questions
um perhaps your questions could have
been quicker it won't be a question
so councilwood can can you um would you
like to say anything else add anything
on this once yes providing it it's very
short it's just to say
we mustn't be scared of causing the
assistant directors to choose to to move
on it's natural it's healthy in an
organization
it creates opportunities for other more
junior staff how do we expect them to
get those opportunities if we don't
allow them that natural progression
within the organization where they we
can actually retain their expertise it's
not a question of always losing out its
opportunities as well
um to to encourage more junior people
and the good the brilliant thing about
that is those junior people then move on
to the minimum pay rate pay point on
that range so it's entirely affordable
and as michelle kirk who presented to us
earlier said
those people that we recruit as as new
assistant directors they're not the
finished article
so we should be more confident about the
possibility of our own corporate
managers applying for those assistant
direct roles
and in some ways someone staying in an
assistant director role for years and
years can um cause
um
you know those those managers to to have
to look elsewhere outside of the
organization because there's just no
prospect for them
um
our whole senior leadership team cost is
about
000 a year
that seems high to me and we're thinking
about increasing it by another 120 or so
taking over half a million and that
doesn't even include just corporate uh
you know our other management costs our
other corporate managers
um it just seems it just seems um a
a hammers cracker nut
thank you
captain award
thank you chairman um
before i make my final comments i just
wanted to clarify some things about the
numbers um for councillors mabry and and
melanie barrett
the tables one and two on page 263 do
give the numbers both the savings and
the costs as they evolve over the four
year period
i know councillor barrett has provided
some alternative numbers but
the numbers without any um
real explanation i don't understand them
certainly michelle kirk and suzanne
hughes didn't understand them
the numbers here are the numbers that we
need to go by um
the 33
on cost
edition
is clear it's clearly stated in 9.6 and
and the impact of that is is also
clearly stated there in 9.6
market forces supplement um both our um
guests did mention the fact that we do
pay market forces supplements we have to
so so those are the facts about the
numbers but
let's just get on to the the actual
paper itself
i do understand members um
uh real concerns and and
i do detect anger as well uh
and i can understand that it is
something we're we're asking you a lot
here
um these are significant risers but
that's only because we haven't addressed
this properly over the past 10 years and
we've allowed ourselves to fall behind
yes
it will be of concern to our residents
and quite rightly so i understand that
what would be more concern though is if
we start
not to be able to deliver services and
council mccraw
addressed this point
we need good staff to deliver good
services
and that's increasingly a fact as um
council's work becomes more complex and
um
and requires that the level of people to
do that
um
we talk we talked a lot about vacancies
at various levels and the fact that
there are gaps
um and uh
talked a bit about planning officers yes
that we have huge um problems in
recruiting
people at that level um to do those
particular jobs but it isn't just
those jobs it's all jobs within the
council that
we have problems with and particularly
the senior jobs and our senior senior
leadership team do do jobs just as much
as anyone at any level does a job it is
a senior job it is a very
um responsible job
we can argue whether the money we pay
now or what we have proposed in this
paper is as excessive or not but the
fact the matter is
we live in
in
in a market economy and
the
salaries are determined by supply and
demand
there's been talk about the fact that we
need to address supply of course we need
to address supply but this is a problem
that this country is facing
in all sorts of
industries all sorts of jobs
there are vacancies there the supply is
not meeting the demand and it's hitting
us here particularly in our senior team
it may
yes i understand it's unpalatable but
the fact the matter is
it'll actually cost us a lot more if we
don't do this if we start to lose people
then we have to rely on interims
if we can't
now we we we've got an interim in place
for the well-being and community's role
fine
if we hadn't had a resignation that was
withdrawn we would have had to recruit
to that role and almost certainly
another interim
what is clear though
from discussions i've had with michelle
kirk is that recruiting a section 151
officer is going to be incredibly
difficult it's going to be impossible at
the current salaries
it's going to be difficult at the the
newly new proposed salaries here
but we must have a 151 officer it's a
statutory role we can't do without so
that means an interim
and i have asked michelle kirk how much
would an interim 151 officer cost at
least a thousand pounds a day
that's not just uh chief is far more
than a chief executive and will lose all
of the benefit that this
paper could provide in just that one
position if we have to rely on that we
council simon barrett talks about the
budget yes of course and i'm acutely
aware of that as cabinet member for
finance
but if we have to rely on interims
that's our budget blown out the window
we're in very difficult situation here
so
i can i can see from or tell from the
the way that the debate has gone this
paper is unlikely to get approved but at
some point it will have to come back
we will have to address this issue
i'll leave it at that chairman that's
probably all i've got to say thank you
thank you ever so much council award
um right i'd now like to
ask our corporate manager governance and
civic office
to conduct the vote which will be a roll
call thank you thank you chair and when
i call your name if you can respond for
against or abstention thank you
councillor arthi
councillor ayers
councillor melanie barrett
councillor simon barrett
councillor peter beer
councillor dave busby
councillor sue carpendale
councillor trevor creswell
councillor derrick davis
councillor mick fraser
councillor rick hardacre
councillor john hinton
councillor brynne huron
councillor lee jameson
councillor robert lindsey
councillor elizabeth malveazy
councillor margaret mabry
john nunn
councillor adrian osborne
councillor jan osborne
councillor allison owen
councillor lee parker
yes
that's the stephen plum
councillor john ward
okay just a few seconds and i'll come
back to you with the totals
14 15 16 17
[Music]
chair the votes are as follows
it was 8 4 17 against and one abstention
so those recommendations were lost
yeah can we have everybody back in
i'd like to
return to the agenda on item 16 please
uh which is bc 2118
uh revisions of internal neighborhood
planning procedures
and i would like to invite client
council client varthy to introduce paper
bc 2118 and move the recommendations in
the report thank you council arthi
thank you gemma
yes this should i hope be a bit shorter
we've come a long way since our first
few parishes began the neighbourhood
planning journey our decision making
procedures have served us well and we
continue to find ways to improve the way
we interact with neighbourhood planned
groups placing placing greater emphasis
on the earlier informative stages and
most importantly of all we continue to
think about what we can do better
the report before you today is i hope
self-explanatory it looks at the two key
regulatory
processes that fall to the council
firstly our decision making on the
recommendations set out in the
independent examiners report and our
advancement of the plan to the
referendum that's regulation 17a
and secondly
subject to a majority yes vote our
adoption of the plan that's regulation
18a
the report proposes changes to the the
agreed procedures which with appropriate
checks in place should ensure that we
can be better smarter and swifter
in the way we guide neighborhood plans
through these stages
[Applause]
in bava 10 neighborhood plans have been
through the examination process and of
those five have been formally adopted
and five are in the final stages of
being modified prior to being made ready
to go to a local referendum
in all cases no objections were raised
by either the district council
or the parish council to the
implementing of the examiner's
recommendations
that would suggest that our early
engagement with these groups is working
i trust the council will agree with me
that the proposed changes to how we
manage regulation 17a and 17 and 18a
stages are both sensible and practical
in simple terms it removes the need for
cabinet to approve the progression to
referendum
and it removes the need for council to
adopt the neighborhood plan
after the majority yes vote
i propose the recommendations in 3.1 and
3.2 at page 275 of the agenda paper
thank you thank you council arthur could
i have a second
council busby
i've now
moved to questions
as before
councillors can ask as many questions
that must be relevant to the subject
under discussion there must be a
question and i hasten to add that
we are
trying to move as quickly as we can i'm
not trying to be
not trying to
not be able to have every counsellor
make a representation
so can i have a question please for
client
any questions council maybe
thank you mr chairman um
my question is can we not go to the vape
please
thank you thank you councillor barrett
um
so we've already had this do we need to
debate here if there's no debate we can
go straight to is there any debate on
these questions
then i'll go to the um
i'll go to the vote
uh as proposed by uh council maybe and
certainly both councillor barrett oh
all those in favor
thank you that is carrie chair
yeah thank you all for that
we now come
to uh
that is carried
council
item 17 council appointments
17a
election chairman of license in the
regulatory committee
chairman say
may i have nominations for the chair of
license in the regulatory john ward
yeah i'd like to nominate councillor
dawson for this role um councillor
dawson
knows the subject very well um she will
be an excellent chair for this committee
um and it will be replacing one
conservative chair with with another so
i'd like to have a second of castle
dawson please
could i have a second chance
mr chairman i'd like to propose
councillor mayberry i think should be an
excellent chairman for this committee as
well i don't think the political uh
inclinations of whoever's going to be
chairman are particularly relevant it's
whether who's capable of the job and
who's here tonight which is obviously
significant as well
so i would like to suggest right to
propose counselor maybe
cancer
plum sorry councillor dawson was
unavoidably
absent this evening because of another
um
appointment which unfortunately has
clashed with this she would have been
here but this was a very last minute
change to her schedule
and it was unavoidable so that's why
she's not here this evening but
she has a valid excuse thank you council
award are there any other further
nominations
i sure they'll move to the vote
thank you chair i intend to take this
vote by the show of hands so all those
in favor of councillor dawson to be
licensing regulatory chair
can you put your hands up please and
wait while we count thank you
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven i'll make it yeah
okay and all of those in favor
councillor maybe can you put your hands
up
are there any abstentions
one
is there another abstention
it just doesn't add up we're one missing
we're one person missing so i'm going to
have to take the first vote again
can i have norma can i have the vote for
councillor dawson again please so we can
just check that vote again
have you counted the chair 12
12 that's 12.
thank you um we
so um councillor mabry um has
had 13 votes and council dawson 12 votes
so councillor mabry's um vote is carried
thank you
thank you very much everyone i will do
my best i declare that councillor maybe
is julie appointed as the chair of
license in the regulatory committee
thank you
now move to
item 18 motions on notice
[Music]
and i'll have a motion here
received from councilman mulvasi
would you like to move your motion
council later
yes can i do i introduce it yes
thank you
um i bring to council this evening a
motion on street lighting
and i'm very pleased to bring this
motion to full council this evening bdc
recognizes that street lighting plays an
important part in our climate change and
biodiversity plans
not only can it be controlled to reduce
cost in our carbon footprint but by
installing the correct type of light we
can protect our nocturnal wildlife
currently led lights are being fitted
because they're cheaper which while
being a positive move on one hand has a
very negative impact on the other
as a society we've moved towards wanting
blue white light and it is this blue
white light that is killing off
nocturnal wildlife
the wildlife is confused it affects how
they behave
and you may think it's very funny but it
affects their reproduction
so that it's estimated that 40 of all
insect insects
currently
will become extinct
in the next decades
i ask that you approve the motion so
that we can produce a biodiversity
biodiversity supplementary planning
document that provides guidance on how
to protect our nocturnal friends on who
our futures so very much depend
thank you very much i propose this
motion
could i have a second to please counsel
jameson
do you wish to speak
um i won't say too much chair i'd just
like to thank councillor malveezy for
bringing this motion before council you
see then this is a motion which is also
being presented by the green group mid
suffolk on
thursday i believe so it can be a joint
um
jointly delivered by both councils
um probably artificial light and light
pollution is called causing big problems
to humans and wildlife and the
environment so
this commotion can help reduce the
effects of artificial light on our
district it will benefit all of us so
i'm happy to second the motion
jameson um
now like to go to debate
uh
three ones
one counsellor for three minutes and it
will be time
any anybody wish duke councillor hinton
you mr chairman well i'm in favor of
seeing uh
some of the
street lighting
turned off
and
especially in the rural areas because it
does have a detrimental effect on the
wildlife it also
has a detrimental effect on being able
to enjoy the night sky and we have seen
recently with the cabinet reshuffle
where ministers have said that people
who live in villages should get used to
buying a torch
so that they can see to get around it is
nice to have a dark sky
and
be able to turn the night the
light off in your bedroom at night and
go to sleep because it's dark rather
than because there's a street light
outside um so i'm
um i think this is a
a good move forward i think perhaps a
little bit complicated
with some of the the lighting that's
proposed but i just hope that the
provisions of the mppf are taken into
account by the county council because it
says in there that you can have areas
without lighting if it's against the uh
environment of the
the ambiance of the of the general area
but of course in the past street lights
have been stuck in purely because the
county council wouldn't accept the road
if they weren't put in
trevor
yeah i think it's a good idea um i do
think the lights the bulb needs to be a
certain type of bulb maybe for the
insects or whatever but
i also believe that uh people who live
in villages um where there's maybe a
local pub or somewhere that they have
the uh there should be a way that they
get home safely
and also where there is violence in um
when people get attacked because it's
dark i i do think that you've got to
have a balance so i believe there should
be light into a certain time at night
thank you
any other
council wish to speak on this today
council plum
thank you chair um i'd just like to make
the comment that i'm i'm part of a
parish council that's spent the last 15
years being persuaded by suffolk county
council to put led lights in and they
spent thousands no hundreds of thousands
of pounds replacing a large number of
lights and therefore i'm wondering with
talking about suffolk county council
being a partner
how on earth are we going to bring him
on board because they've been promoting
led lights ferociously over the last 15
years
and many villagers particularly take
themselves we have well over 120 led
lights in place
thank you
anybody else wish to speak
oh council busby i'd do a very good part
just a quick question will the bio
diversity supplementary planning
document come back to council
or will it be approved by
councillor arthi or
it'll come to council
thank you
councillor lindsay
i see your hands up
oh thank you just very briefly to
um
perhaps address some of councillor plums
concerns
um i happen to sit on the um
biodiversity panel at suffolk county
council but
the policy development panel
and this has come up as an issue
um about it so so the county council
rest assured they are
looking at this that the fact that led
the intensity of white led light
and this motion doesn't say that we've
got to replace them all again it's just
talking about lower intensity
um
and thinking about thinking more about
you know putting the emphasis more on on
having less light and less intensity
thanks
lindsay
councillor arthi
can i ask just a quick question i
thought the councilor malvizi said when
she was um proposing her motion in some
of the the extra stuff does it did she
say that it affects sex lives
that's completion of uh is that
completion of the debate uh um
just ask cancer do you malvais do you
wish to add anything
um
you can put a filter on the led or you
can choose it's been like christmas the
tree the christmas tree lights
when they first came out they were a
soft warm
glow
and then everybody went blue white
because it was sharper and brighter and
leds are exactly the same because
they're led lights as well
yeah thank you mr chairman just uh
answering uh really give some more um
detail for councillor plum um suffolk is
working with um their partner
es and they started replacing 43
400 street lanterns with leds they're
going to be variable intensity so they
can change the intensity of them and the
extent that they're switched on
suffolk's responsible for sixty thousand
street lights and also uh nine and a
half
thousand signs and bollards and they'll
be they are working with boroughs
districts and town councils on this so
yeah they're all in board working
together
i'm interested in 180 at clemson which
was sold to us by suffolk county council
i'm lucky
yeah could i could i now ask members to
go to the vote please on this
i will now ask the
government's officer and civic office to
conduct the electric
electronic vote
at the last vote you decided just like
that that we'd have a show of hands and
now you're saying we're going back to
electronic vote what what is the
difference it's entirely up to our
government yeah right that's valued i
accept that yeah um just to to say that
actually if we do it by the modern.gov
that vote is reported on the website the
next morning when we do it hands up we
don't have that facility so it's the
transparency that we stick to modern.gov
if we can thank you so on this case we
will be opening the vote and that is
going blue as we speak so if you could
cost your vote thank you
thank you
four thank you
four
okay
you're four as well
i have twenty uh three four and two
abstentions oh no twenty four four sorry
i've forgotten cancer maybe twenty four
four and two abstentions thank you
so that is carried thank you
that is carrie
um i now like to go to item 18 b
to consider the motional notice received
from councillor jameson
councillor jameson would you like to
move your motion uh thank you chair a
motion before you used to ask the
council to sign up to the client as a
client to be a client partner on the
consider a constructor scheme i did send
out details or some information on the
considerate constructor scheme
last night it's a code that can meet
sites and companies and suppliers
registered to the scheme to care about
appearance safety respect the community
protect the environment and value the
workforce becoming a client partner is
free
and demonstrates that us as a council is
an
organization that practically chooses to
demonstrate its commitment to raising
standards in the construction industry
will be recognized by the public and
those working on site as an organization
that
places huge importance on showing care
and consideration towards the local
community
the environment and the welfare of the
workforce
client partnership member companies
agree to recommend the scheme
registration tool sites under the
control and are expected to encourage
conformance with all aspects of the
schemes
code
on the original site
it's already many major companies
already signed up as well as several
councils already signed up as client
partners
and to say it's free and most likely
to ask the council to approve this
motion
thank you
have a second please
counselor lindsay thank you would you
like to speak
um
that observer right to if again
well i'll now go to debate uh but um
we must move ahead oh councillor hinton
i beg your pardon
quick just a quick question um i see
this relates to sites being registered
rather than
developers or construction companies or
whatever so if somebody's outside of our
county do we have the ability to
tell them the planning legislation that
they can't they've got to sign their
sites up
we can put wording
in
that would um encourage
people to sign up yeah for plan yeah
depends on the wording i believe
would a client partnership member
company be somebody working on behalf of
this council
rather than a developer applying to this
council i mean i'm not sure can we
apply it to uh planning applications i'm
not sure we can but i read this as being
that the considerate constructor
would be somebody working with us i
happen to know
i've seen our homes doing a site in
branson
and i saw this sign on their fence today
and i recognized it thanks to lee so
it is happening already i suspect but
is it just for ourselves or can we
impose this on developers in our area
uh
it is for ourselves but i've been drive
by um
a contact within the company that we can
put wording in place that would um
allow us to use it for developers as
well now i need to confirm that but
primarily is for our sites
thank you chair i just wanted to i just
wanted to ask because obviously this is
more on as you said the client partner
side of this but um when we are looking
for contractors to do the work that we
do which um this might be a question for
an officer that's not going to be able
to answer this at the moment but in
terms of the health and safety side of
these things when we
appoint these contractors do we have any
sort of i assume we do sort of like
questionnaires that will ask them for
their confidence on things like this
because obviously we want to have the
contractors on site that are going to be
you know obviously it's not everything
to be a part of these things but at
least show that they achieve a certain
standard so if we have a questionnaire
in place that already accounts for these
kind of things then i just think it
would be helpful if we didn't have that
in place to have that because obviously
it would just it would show that we are
as well as a council making a commitment
to that we're also making a commitment
to getting the contractors on site that
also adhere to these kind of regulations
obviously there's many different
accrediting bodies that do this kind of
thing
but um yeah more of a question for the
health and safety compliance side i
suppose thank you
anymore for debate sorry okay
councilwood
yeah um
just a a couple of points um
we we already asked our contractors to
um to sign up for this on our key
construction projects and uh we're
already delivering a lot of the key
benefits of this this scheme which is
good um in terms of the terms of
reference for client partners
um
several of those we we already follow um
there's one there in terms of the the
point scoring which
will take some work i think in to to um
to make sure we can achieve that but
the average score of 30 points or more
is i think about 60 percent of the total
50 points so that shouldn't be too
onerous
um nine local authorities uh
amidst the currently of county councils
and unitaries we would be the first
district council so um that would be
some kudos for us if we were to sign up
to this so um i'm i'm happy to support
this it's um it seems a no-brainer quite
honestly
anything to
add
no nothing else
i'll go to the vote now so i'll ask our
corporate manager governance and civic
office to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair that vote is now open if
councillors can cast their vote thank
you
maybe can i take your vote
thank you
hinton are you still having problems
thank you oh no
i'm through so can i take it
oh it's just gone through sorry yeah
okay lovely thank you
that is 25 votes for
26 um with cancer mayberries thank you
so much
that is carried
um i'll now go to item 18 c to consider
the motion i noticed you received from
councillor lindsay
lindsay would you like to move your
motion
um
yes i um so i wasn't aware that i
thought i think there was an amendment
coming but do i
[Music]
that we consider
creating a move into a committee
system
jameson
council ward
yeah thanks sherman
when i became leader nearly four years
ago i did say i would try to build an
administration that was more inclusive
and to that end i included an
independent council of davis in the
cabinet
moreover i made a commitment at the
february meeting this year that the
cabinet would look at ways of improving
engagement and communication with the
rest of the council
however it is clear from conversations i
have had that there is still more to do
which is evidenced by desire to explore
the option of reverting to the committee
system of governance
as many believe that this would be more
inclusive it is now time that council
has the opportunity to debate and make a
decision
however in order to inform a debate at
council we need to define what sort of
committee system would be appropriate
and identify its benefits and
disadvantages in comparison with
possible improvements to what we have
now
both in cabinet and council
i would therefore like to propose the
following amendment to this motion
after five years of the current leader
cabinet governance model the council
believes it is time to review how
effectively this is working and assess
it against the committee governance
model
council will therefore instruct the
constitution working group and officers
to define the details including benefits
and disadvantages of an improved cabinet
model and a suitable committee model the
working group should report back to the
first full council meeting after the
20th of december 2021 with these two
options to allow council to decide which
it prefers with a review to implementing
any changes at the annual council
meeting in may 2022
i'd like to have a second to please
council lindsay do you accept this
amendment
uh i do
so what will you go to
just go to debate
yes i'd like to now go to
the council again
thank you chair so is that debate or
questions chair
no it's a good day
just about is it oh okay fine well i've
got a question
so
for what it's worth i actually i
actually think this is probably a
sensible compromise uh for for what it's
worth i have some sympathy actually with
a move back to to committee system
having experienced both but
my question is
um what what's the scenario if uh for
example if baba district council chose
to operate a committee system and um
colleagues at mid suffolk um chose a
cabinet system
chairman i think this one can possibly
come in my direction of course depends
of course if you've got any staff left
to support you a big sarcastic
i couldn't resist it um so it doesn't
cause us any issues at all it depends on
the nature of the committee model that
you adopt if you go down that route so
obviously there's a variety of different
types of committee model in the same way
there are a variety of different cabinet
models obviously you don't have the full
blown version of cabinet model at the
moment so for example although you have
portfolio holders they don't have direct
delegated powers to be able to make
decisions without bringing them back to
cabinets if you think of that as a
comparison to a committee system you can
have a committee system with portfolio
holders i believe that may well have
been similar to the community system
that you had in the past so not that
very different to a cabinet model
alternatively you could have a committee
system without uh portfolio holders
where you've got a committee for each of
the portfolio areas a housing committee
a environment committee and so on and so
forth
that would create
not challenges but obviously points of
difference so if you were trying to do
the same report in mid suffolk and
you're trying to do the same report in
baber the root through would be
different that's the only issue
has the oh castle lindsay
yeah just to explain why i accepted this
amendment
um
whatever happens today whatever we talk
about today we can't i'm told we can't
legally
decide on going to the committee system
today
even though i would like to um because
five years isn't up
until the 7th of the 20th so we'd have
to have another debate anyway and that's
why my emotions said
original motion said um
consider
consider moving to committee system
because we we have to have that debate
so
um
[Music]
you know so i think i think it's
reasonable to um
to to to to have that debate
uh when we're allowed to have it and um
i hope
that um
[Music]
people will will vote the way
i want which is to have a committee
system but you know
it it may not be it may not be so
cancer do you wish to
wish to add anything
no i don't think so um as council
lindsay has has indicated the um the
substantive debate will take place
in the new year at some point so
that's that's when we'll have uh the
real funny games
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair last one of the evening
that motion is now as amended if you
could cast your votes please thank you
thank you and counselor maybe
anybody else who's packed away
can we just do hands up then please
that's carried anyway thank you
can i just um
members can i just congratulate you all
for managing to get through this before
the uh
before 10 o'clock and
the next day
of our next meeting will be tuesday 23rd
of november
2021 at 5 30. thank you all for
attending and for your
you